Hello everyone.
大家好。
My name is Josh.
我叫乔什。
I am from Pennsylvania and on the 20th of April of 2025, I hit my five-year sobriety mark.
我来自宾夕法尼亚州，2025 年 4 月 20 日，我达到了五年清醒标记。
I just wanted you guys to know that in my deepest, darkest time is getting to where I am today, going from living in a ditch to going to a rehab, uh, sober house, so on and so forth.
我只是想让你们知道，在我最深、最黑暗的时刻，我经历了今天的处境，从住在沟里到去戒毒所，呃，清醒的房子，等等。
I now met the woman of my dreams and I'm soon asking her to take my hand in marriage and Without how I met your mother I wouldn't have made it through those deep dark days And I just wanted to take the opportunity to thank the cast and everyone with all their hard work and tell you all I appreciate it so much.
我现在遇到了我梦想中的女人，我很快就会向她求婚，如果没有我遇见你母亲，我就不可能度过那些黑暗的日子，我只是想借此机会感谢演员们和每个人的辛勤工作，并告诉你们我非常感激。
Thank you Please permit me to tell you everything in New York City.
谢谢您请允许我告诉您纽约市的一切。
Wow, what a way to start.
哇，真是一个开始的方式。
Hello, everyone.
大家好。
I'm Josh Radner.
我是乔什·拉德纳。
I'm joined as ever by my friend Craig Thomas.
我的朋友克雷格·托马斯一如既往地加入了我的行列。
Hello, Craig.
你好，克雷格。
Hello, Josh.
你好，乔什。
Welcome to another episode of How We Made Your Mother.
欢迎收看《我们如何成就了你的母亲》的另一集。
We're discussing the program, the series, the television show, how I met your mother, which Craig created with Carter Bayes.
我们正在讨论克雷格与卡特贝叶斯共同创作的节目、连续剧、电视节目以及《我是如何遇见你母亲的》。
based.
基于。
It ran for nine years.
它运行了九年。
People still love it.
人们仍然喜欢它。
We are interrogating exactly what Josh shared with us.
我们正在询问乔什与我们分享的确切内容。
Why how I met your mother is such good medicine for people in hard times.
为什么我和你母亲的相遇对那些处于困境的人来说是一剂良药。
Josh, if you're listening and I hope you are, thank you for my gosh.
乔希，如果你在听的话，我希望你在听，谢谢你的天哪。
Yeah.
是的。
Thank you for the gift of that voice note.
感谢您赠送的语音留言。
We're so glad.
我们很高兴。
Do you say you hit five years of of surprise.
你说你打了五年的惊喜。
Five years.
五年了。
No small thing.
这可不是小事。
It's a huge way.
这是一个巨大的方式。
Somebody even say it's a major accomplishment.
有人甚至说这是一项重大成就。
Major accomplishment.
主要成就。
And yeah, we're thrilled.
是的，我们很兴奋。
We're thrilled for you and congrats on the almost engagement.
我们为你感到兴奋，并祝贺你即将订婚。
Yeah, we're so happy to be here.
是的，我们很高兴来到这里。
That was almost a proposal.
这几乎是一个提议。
That was almost it's like, when is this air?
这几乎就像是，这是什么时候的空气？
When's he gonna ask?
他什么时候会问？
You know, no.
你知道，不。
He has to come to a Josh Radner show on tour because that's where all the proposals are happening these days.
他必须参加乔什·拉德纳 (Josh Radner) 的巡回演出，因为这些天所有的求婚都在那里发生。
It's happening.
它正在发生。
So we have a, you know, this is a great extra special episode because we have a guest star today who is not only a hilarious writer but he is one of the handsomest comedy writers in Hollywood.
所以我们有一个，你知道，这是一个很棒的特别节目，因为今天我们有一位客串明星，他不仅是一位搞笑的作家，而且是好莱坞最英俊的喜剧作家之一。
Please welcome a person who was on the show.
请欢迎一位参加节目的人。
Is this correct correct from day one?
从第一天起这就是正确的吗？
Day one, pre-day one to day final, yeah.
第一天，第一天前到最后一天，是的。
Day one to day final.
第一天到最后一天。
One of the all-time greats.
历史上最伟大的人物之一。
How much are mother writers?
妈妈作家多少钱？
Ladies and gentlemen, Chris Harris.
女士们先生们，克里斯·哈里斯。
Chris Harris is the author of game night which we're gonna talk about hi Chris hi guys I'm so thank you for letting me be here and and if you please elaborate on the handsome part Say that you resemble the great Welsh actor Michael Sheen have you heard this before he's he's a hot preacher or hot No, no that's Andrew Scott the hot actor he was being compared to, he was like, even that is the hot breeze?
克里斯·哈里斯（Chris Harris）是《游戏之夜》的作者，我们要谈论嗨克里斯·嗨，伙计们，我非常感谢你们让我来到这里，如果你们能详细说明一下帅气的部分，说你像伟大的威尔士演员迈克尔·辛（Michael Sheen），你在他之前听过这个吗？
I got a young guy in Thelma and Louise, no, that's Brad Pitt.
我在《塞尔玛与路易丝》中有一个年轻人，不，那是布拉德·皮特。
Which James Bond was he?
他是哪个詹姆斯·邦德？
Because yes, I get them all.
因为是的，我都明白了。
Well, we're thrilled to have you here, Chris.
好吧，我们很高兴你能来到这里，克里斯。
Do you feel complete on the hands of Miss or do you need more?
在Miss的帮助下你感觉很完整还是你还需要更多？
No, that was plenty.
不，已经足够了。
It went right into very quickly so well we're we're discussing your great season one episode I think it's episode 15 is that right Alex Wow episode 15 of season one it's called game night Chris also wrote episode five or six five at six okay awesome it was five the one in the club with the subtitles hilarious episode you're you really crushed your season one episodes Chris this is a We're coming up.
它很快就进入了所以我们正在讨论你伟大的第一季剧集我想这是第15集是对的亚历克斯哇第一季的第15集它被称为游戏之夜克里斯还写了第五集或第六集五点六点好吧太棒了这是俱乐部里的第五集带有字幕的搞笑剧集你真的粉碎了你的第一季剧集克里斯这是我们即将到来的。
There's another one coming up.
还有一个即将到来。
Great episode.
很棒的一集。
So let's put you on the spot right away.
因此，让我们立即将您带到现场。
We often, by the way, what was the air date of this, Alex?
顺便问一下，我们经常问这个节目的播出日期是哪天，亚历克斯？
This is on February 27, 2006.
这是2006年2月27日。
Ah, a simpler time.
啊，更简单的时光。
Chris, I often ask Craig to do this, but let's just test your memory.
克里斯，我经常要求克雷格这样做，但我们只是测试一下你的记忆力。
Can you give a quick synopsis of what happens in this episode?
你能简单介绍一下这一集中发生的事情吗？
The logline.
故事梗概。
Sure, I can.
当然，我可以。
They, during a game night run by Marshall, a secret comes out about Barney.
在马歇尔主持的一场比赛之夜，他们发现了一个关于巴尼的秘密。
and in order for everyone to hear his story, he gets the most embarrassing moments from each of the other cast members along the way.
为了让每个人都听到他的故事，他一路上从其他演员那里得到了最尴尬的时刻。
Great, that's good.
太好了，那就好。
21 minutes, TV, 14.
21 分钟，电视，14。
Close caption.
关闭标题。
All right, well then, we've never had those actions.
好吧，那么，我们从来没有采取过这些行动。
And do you have any kind of greatest tips, like what is your memory of this, like in the writer's room?
你有什么最棒的建议吗？比如你对此的记忆是什么，比如在作家的房间里？
How did the story start?
故事是如何开始的？
How did it break?
怎么破的？
What were the main, inciting ideas?
主要的、有启发性的想法是什么？
I remember it as almost being a little bit of a, the same way Barney's story came out piecemeal.
我记得它几乎是一点点的，就像巴尼的故事是零碎的一样。
I remember being a little bit of that slog in terms of how to structure.
我记得在如何构建方面遇到了一些困难。
But the starting point, I think Carter and Craig came in with this Barney's backstory.
但首先，我认为卡特和克雷格是带着巴尼的背景故事进来的。
I think this was one of your original pitches, Craig.
我认为这是你最初的推销之一，克雷格。
I don't think it was on that original sheet, but it was definitely like in the back of our head about like we're gonna peel back the suit and see who that guy used to be before he kind of got in there.
我不认为它是在原来的床单上，但它绝对就像在我们的脑海中一样，就像我们要剥开防护服，看看那个人在他进来之前曾经是谁。
And then I don't remember if we kind of had the overt like Star Wars references at that point or if those came later.
然后我不记得我们当时是否有类似《星球大战》的公开参考，或者这些是后来出现的。
But I literally, I think we might have had the, Star Wars might have inspired this idea.
但从字面上看，我认为我们可能有，星球大战可能激发了这个想法。
Like seeing Darth Vader become Darth Vader in the third prequel that was out and it was for a bunch of the Sith.
就像在第三部前传中看到达斯·维德变成了达斯·维德，那是为了一群西斯。
That idea of that sequence, I think may have been the inspiration for like just the way we would learn Barney's backstory.
我认为这个序列的想法可能就是我们了解巴尼背景故事的方式的灵感。
I feel like that's right.
我觉得是这样没错。
I feel like you guys had this amazing notion of let's tell an origin story for Barney.
我觉得你们有一个令人惊奇的想法，让我们来讲述巴尼的起源故事。
Let's show how he was a hippie in the late 90s and what turned him into the suit wearing, some might say monster that he became.
让我们来看看他是如何成为 90 年代末的嬉皮士，以及是什么让他穿上西装，有些人可能会说他变成了怪物。
And then I think we had, so we had this great story and most of the discussion in the room was how do we build up an episode around that that's going to rival the story.
然后我想我们做到了，所以我们有了这个很棒的故事，房间里的大部分讨论都是我们如何围绕这个故事建立一个与故事相媲美的剧集。
And I was flipping through, I looked quickly through some of the room notes, which are almost into cypherable, not just because.
我正在翻阅，我快速地浏览了一些房间笔记，这些笔记几乎是可以密码的，不仅仅是因为。
I love that you have that.
我喜欢你有这个。
Did you find that in an old email or something?
您是否在旧电子邮件或其他内容中发现了这一点？
Or do you have like an old folder deep, you know, like I had to peel the cobwebs away as I dove deeper and deeper into my Mac.
或者你是否有一个像旧文件夹一样深的文件夹，就像我在深入使用 Mac 时必须剥掉蜘蛛网一样。
You know, link to archments like the Constitution.
你知道，链接到宪法等拱门。
Yeah, yeah, earlier and earlier versions of Word documents.
是的，是的，Word 文档的早期版本。
And it felt like we, it looked like we, you know, for a while it was talk about like, is it all about, they hear about the video and it's all about trying to track down this video and Barney's giving them clues about where it might be?
感觉就像我们，看起来我们，你知道，有一段时间我们在谈论，他们听说了这段视频，都是关于试图追踪这段视频，而巴尼给了他们关于它可能在哪里的线索？
So it got very complicated.
所以事情变得非常复杂。
And then at some point it hit, it hit that I saw there's a little bullet point that something like everyone has to tell their story in order to get more of Barney's story.
然后在某个时刻，我突然意识到有一个小要点，每个人都必须讲述自己的故事才能了解更多巴尼的故事。
And from there, and from there I think it started to crack And it was like, oh, it's a game night.
从那里开始，我认为它开始破裂，就像，哦，这是一个游戏之夜。
And I remember the feeling that it can't just be that we have this funny backstory.
我记得当时的感觉：我们不仅仅是有这个有趣的背景故事。
It was, how do we make an interesting and the present tense?
问题是，我们如何创造一个有趣的现在时？
And how is there some kind of goal and forward momentum in the present tense and stakes?
现在时态和利害关系中如何存在某种目标和前进动力？
And I think in figuring out what are the stakes, we realized like Ted and Robin, Ted and Victoria, and that got added on.
我认为在弄清楚风险是什么时，我们意识到像泰德和罗宾、泰德和维多利亚一样，而且这一点也被添加了。
And then all of a sudden it was an episode.
然后突然之间就出现了一个插曲。
It wasn't just, here's a funny clip show of stuff that happened in the past.
这不仅仅是，这是过去发生的事情的有趣剪辑。
So it needs to be, we needed a present day, conundrum or conundrum, conundrum, plural.
所以它需要是，我们需要一个现在，难题或难题，难题，复数。
And I've never said that word before, but I'm just gonna pretend it, I say it all the time.
我以前从未说过这个词，但我只是假装它，我一直这么说。
I love it.
我喜欢它。
And I remember that was hard to find, wasn't it, Chris?
我记得那很难找到，不是吗，克里斯？
I feel like we're hitting our heads against the wall.
我感觉我们正在用头撞墙。
Like we had the Darth Vader nugget and we didn't, the rest was actually hard to get.
就像我们有达斯维德金块但我们没有一样，其余的实际上很难获得。
Do you remember that one?
你还记得那个吗？
And, you know, looking at it now, because after rewatching it, I was like, oh wow, it's pretty complicated.
而且，你知道，现在看它，因为在重看之后，我就想，哦，哇，它非常复杂。
I mean, because Ted and Robin and Victoria, there's a lot going on and there are these micro expressions and there's like things that somebody says that somebody else takes the other way.
我的意思是，因为泰德、罗宾和维多利亚，发生了很多事情，有这些微表情，比如有人说别人采取了相反的方式。
And Ted's story, which is great and it adds to the lore, but it also causes this understandable moment of friction and confusion with Victoria.
特德的故事很棒，它增加了传说，但它也导致了与维多利亚之间的摩擦和困惑，这是可以理解的。
Like we keep talking about how great it is when you have something like that's both character revealing and plot forwarding and funny all at the same time.
就像我们一直在谈论当你拥有这样的东西时，它是多么伟大，既能揭示角色，又能推动情节，同时又很有趣。
Like that seemed to be the sweet spot for these episodes, especially in some of the B stories.
这似乎是这些剧集的最佳点，尤其是在一些 B 故事中。
Like we were talking about another episode where the, like little moments in the B story actually end up having major consequences for the rest of this.
就像我们正在谈论另一集一样，B 故事中的小时刻实际上最终对其余部分产生了重大影响。
Major consequences.
重大后果。
It happens in real life, folks.
伙计们，这发生在现实生活中。
We find them in nature.
我们在大自然中找到它们。
And I wrote you this little day to send you in New York City.
今天我写信给你，是为了送你去纽约。
We'll be right back.
我们马上回来。
Hi, I'm Alex Goldman, host of the Hyper-Fixed podcast.
大家好，我是 Alex Goldman，Hyper-Fixed 播客的主持人。
Each week, we take listeners' problems and try to solve them for them.
每周，我们都会收集听众的问题并尝试为他们解决。
problems like, I'm 30 and I'm scared to drive in New York.
比如，我已经 30 岁了，我害怕在纽约开车。
Or why can't I adjust the volume of my car stereo when I'm in reverse?
或者为什么我倒车时无法调节汽车音响的音量？
We also solve non-car related problems.
我们还解决非汽车相关的问题。
If you have a problem, not only will we fix it, we'll expose the hidden systems that cause that problem in the first place.
如果您遇到问题，我们不仅会修复它，还会首先暴露导致该问题的隐藏系统。
That's the Hyper-Fixed Podcast from Radiotopia.
这是来自 Radiotopia 的 Hyper-Fixed 播客。
Find it wherever you find podcasts or at hyperfixedpod.com.
无论您在哪里找到播客或在 hyperfixedpod.com 上都可以找到它。
I have a question for you though, so just so we know how writer's rooms work.
不过我有一个问题想问你，所以我们知道作家室是如何运作的。
So you crack a story, Do you have a beginning, middle, and end by the time you go off to write the first draft?
所以当你破解一个故事时，当你开始写初稿时，你有开头、中间部分和结尾吗？
Definitely, that doesn't mean it doesn't change, but we absolutely, you know, Carter and Craig ran a room, and I've tried to do the same when I've been lucky enough to run shows, where let's make sure that this story is as solid as we can possibly make it, and let's beat out every single scene, every, know what the jokes are, know what the A to B of each scene is, And really feel great about it, because as you know, everything gets thrown at you.
当然，这并不意味着它不会改变，但我们绝对，你知道，卡特和克雷格经营着一个房间，当我有幸经营节目时，我也尝试做同样的事情，让我们确保这个故事尽可能地扎实，让我们击败每一个场景，每一个，知道笑话是什么，知道每个场景的A到B是什么，并且真的感觉很棒，因为如你所知，一切都被扔给你。
Whether it's notes from the Studio Network or suddenly a big set piece that you thought was gonna be hysterical, turns out to not be that hysterical.
无论是来自 Studio Network 的笔记，还是突然出现的一个你认为会歇斯底里的大片段，事实证明并没有那么歇斯底里。
So you have to believe in that internal structure, that basic structure of the story as much as possible.
所以你必须尽可能地相信故事的内部结构、基本结构。
Now that doesn't mean that sometimes we do sort of say, oh, you know what, this isn't working the way we thought it did.
但这并不意味着有时我们会说，哦，你知道吗，这并不像我们想象的那样有效。
But yeah, they were, so, and I'm sure you've heard this before, but like the episode has my name on it, but it's got contributions from every writer in it.
但是，是的，他们是，所以，我相信你以前听说过这个，但就像这一集有我的名字一样，但它得到了每个作家的贡献。
Every writer, it's been through the room multiple, multiple times by the time, especially by the time we get it to air.
每个作家，每次都会多次走过这个房间，尤其是当我们将其播出时。
This is probably a question you'll be uncomfortable in answering, but I want you to try.
你可能不愿意回答这个问题，但我希望你尝试一下。
Are there moments from that draft that made it into the show, that made it onto the air, that are Chris Harris, that are pure Chris Harris, You're like I'm excited and happy about this so many.
选秀中是否有一些时刻进入了节目，进入了广播，那是克里斯·哈里斯，那是纯粹的克里斯·哈里斯，你就像我对此感到兴奋和高兴。
I would say I don't want Chris to be shy so many Chris has such a high hit rate of that in every script he wrote Your praises there's so much.
我想说，我不想让克里斯害羞，克里斯的命中率如此之高，在他写的每个剧本中，你的赞美之词太多了。
There's so much that was that was other people.
有很多事情都是别人的。
I can say that watch him do this Watch him take no credit.
我可以说，看着他这样做，看着他不接受任何功劳。
I know I see all the time the marshal being really good at games and and the and the what runner I am The one runner, I'm pretty sure, was me sitting alone in a cafe or a restaurant somewhere giggling to myself.
我知道我一直看到元帅非常擅长比赛，而我是什么跑步者，我很确定，那个跑步者是我独自坐在咖啡馆或餐馆里，自言自语。
The one runner is funnier every time.
独行者每次都更有趣。
The one runner is so funny.
独行者太搞笑了
It's like a staircase of laughter.
就像笑声的阶梯。
I want to say that it's such a Chris Harris joke.
我想说这就是克里斯·哈里斯的笑话。
Chris Harris is a master at creating these Rube Goldberg machines, sort of joke delivery systems that are like, like being picked up like and you know that this thing is gonna make this sound at this time and this thing can come back around at this time.
Chris Harris 是创造 Rube Goldberg 机器的大师，这是一种笑话传送系统，就像被拿起一样，你知道这个东西会在这个时候发出这种声音，并且这个东西可以在这个时候回来。
And what's the one Marshall says?
马歇尔说了什么？
He doesn't say why he says when is that right?
他没有说为什么他说什么时候是正确的？
Robyn says which I had not did not remember.
罗宾说的我没说过，不记得了。
That made me laugh the hardest of anything.
这让我笑得最厉害。
That was funny.
这很有趣。
That was my two.
那是我的两个。
I totally came out of the blue.
我完全出乎意料。
I mean, watching the whole episode, it kind of, there's a little part of me that made me depressed because I like to think that my writing is getting better and better And over the years, I've just improved.
我的意思是，看完整集，我的一小部分让我感到沮丧，因为我喜欢认为我的写作越来越好，多年来，我刚刚有所进步。
But I looked, I watched the episode, I was like, ah, damn it, you guys are dead.
但我看了这一集，我当时想，啊，该死，你们死定了。
It was my year, 2006, it was my year.
这是我的一年，2006年，这是我的一年。
It wasn't my year, it was so far over the hill.
这不是我的一年，已经过了山头了。
It's not often that you can point to the moment you peaked, but this is it.
你很少能指出自己达到顶峰的那一刻，但就是这样。
That was it, it's just been a very, thankfully, a very slow decline, but a decline nonetheless.
就是这样，谢天谢地，下降非常缓慢，但仍然是下降。
Why did we keep around eight more years after that?
为什么我们在那之后又保留了大约八年？
And slow decline, never.
而且缓慢下降，永远不会。
You kept pitching that watch joke over and over again.
你一遍又一遍地讲那个手表笑话。
No, it's a callback and people will love it.
不，这是一个回调，人们会喜欢它。
You know, I love not only not only is Marshall great at games, my first big laugh when he screams Yahtzee, like that's a pure seagull, just like that's a pure seagull.
你知道，我不仅喜欢马歇尔在比赛中的出色表现，而且当他尖叫“Yahtzee”时我第一次大笑，就像那是一只纯粹的海鸥，就像那是一只纯粹的海鸥。
They probably didn't write it that way.
他们可能不是这样写的。
It's just like a weird take and such a fun word to scream.
这就像一个奇怪的想法和一个有趣的尖叫词。
But where did you guys come up with Marshall's so good at games, he's invented his own?
但是你们从哪里想到马歇尔如此擅长游戏，他还发明了自己的游戏？
Which crazily enough, I never even thought of this.
太疯狂了，我从来没有想到过这一点。
Did that freak Lily out, given what her thought, You guys didn't know that.
考虑到莉莉的想法，这让莉莉感到害怕吗？你们不知道这一点。
We didn't know that, but then we later arrived at Chris.
我们不知道这一点，但后来我们到达了克里斯。
Chasing board game fortunes.
追逐棋盘游戏的财富。
Yeah, we later arrived at the idea that Chris Elliott as her dad would have been this board game inventor and realized there was this kind of overlap.
是的，我们后来想到克里斯·埃利奥特（Chris Elliott）作为她的父亲将是这个棋盘游戏的发明者，并意识到存在这种重叠。
Like she did marry her dad.
就像她嫁给了她爸爸一样。
She did marry her dad.
她确实嫁给了她爸爸。
She was trying to like move on to life and work for the game.
她试图继续为游戏而生活和工作。
We realized that very retroactively though.
不过，我们非常回顾性地意识到了这一点。
I'm not even, I'm not sure we did that on purpose at all.
我什至不确定我们是否是故意这样做的。
I was just like, yeah.
我当时就想，是啊。
But that's another one of those like, those unconscious writer connections that you're making.
但这是另一种类似的，你正在无意识地建立的作家联系。
Unconscious connections.
无意识的联系。
Yeah.
是的。
That's hysterical.
这太歇斯底里了。
I never thought about that.
我从来没有想过这个。
Wow.
哇。
I thought it was particularly funny that Marshall is so good at games.
我觉得特别有趣的是马歇尔如此擅长游戏。
He has to invent his own Like where did that come with?
他必须发明自己的东西，就像它是从哪里来的？
I remember it originally it was it was March Opoli or Marshall Opoli Oh, yeah, we could not get the rights cleared to Marshall Opoli and I remember we were actually on set and we had like we were allowed to use Candyland visually But something about the Opoli was just throwing legal for a loop Wow.
我记得最初是三月奥波利或马歇尔奥波利哦，是的，我们无法获得马歇尔奥波利的权利，我记得我们实际上在片场，我们好像被允许在视觉上使用糖果乐园，但关于奥波利的一些事情只是让法律陷入困境哇。
So you had to go back to a game that's been around for thousands of years, the Mesopotamians didn't copyright that gamut.
所以你必须回到一个已经存在了数千年的游戏，美索不达米亚人并没有拥有该领域的版权。
No.
不。
Who would have thought the Monopoly people would play a real corporate hardball?
谁会想到垄断者会采取真正的企业强硬态度？
You should have paid them in Monopoly, Mark, to see if they were taken in.
马克，你应该在大富翁游戏中付钱给他们，看看他们是否被骗了。
That's why there are so few games that end with Opelie.
这就是为什么以 Opelie 结尾的游戏如此之少。
Rebecca had a question, Chris.
丽贝卡有一个问题，克里斯。
She said, did Chris Harris really hit backgammon that much?
她说，克里斯·哈里斯真的那么会双陆棋吗？
Marshall's like weirdly rage-filled dig at backgammon?
马歇尔就像是在玩西洋双陆棋，充满了奇怪的愤怒？
I feel like maybe you did hate backgammon that much.
我觉得也许你真的那么讨厌双陆棋。
Am I right?
我说得对吗？
I don't think so.
我不这么认为。
In fact, I looked, well, one, I think that if I had to pick, I think that's your joke, Craig.
事实上，我看起来，嗯，一个，我想如果我必须选择的话，我认为那是你的笑话，克雷格。
I could be wrong.
我可能是错的。
Really?
真的吗？
Sure.
当然。
I think so.
我想是的。
And then two, in the first draft, he was just as angry about monopoly, which might have been me.
然后是两个，在初稿中，他对垄断同样感到愤怒，而这可能是我。
I might have hated monopoly enough, but then we just moved that hatred over to a different...
我可能已经足够讨厌垄断了，但后来我们只是把这种仇恨转移到了另一个......
Oh my god, if that unending to me, I literally to this day, I don't really know what that gammon is.
天啊，如果这对我来说永无休止，直到今天，我真的不知道那个金门是什么。
So I can't say I have hold any video against something I don't understand.
所以我不能说我持有任何针对我不理解的东西的视频。
But I think the being really good at games came from you a little Chris, didn't it?
但我认为真正擅长游戏的能力来自于你，小克里斯，不是吗？
Because just to share this and we can edit this out if you want, you're a bit of a, you're a game guy.
因为只是为了分享这个，如果你愿意的话我们可以编辑它，你是一个游戏迷。
You're a scavenger hunt guy.
你是一个寻宝者。
You are an adult, elevated, travel to another city you don't live in, scavenger hunt guy, true or false.
你是一个成年人，地位很高，去另一个你不住的城市旅行，寻宝游戏，无论是真是假。
Why would you, why would you want to edit this out?
你为什么要编辑这个？
Why do you think this is interesting to people about how much I like puzzles and games?
为什么你认为人们对我有多喜欢拼图和游戏很感兴趣？
You know, I do.
你知道，我知道。
This is you, right?
这就是你，对吧？
I love puzzles.
我喜欢拼图。
I did.
我做到了。
Yeah, I used to do these hunts where you drive around for 30 hours in a van with a team going from clue to clue, solving other puzzles.
是的，我曾经做过这样的狩猎活动，你开着一辆货车，和一个团队一起行驶 30 个小时，逐个线索，解决其他谜题。
30 hours.
30小时。
It's crazy.
太疯狂了。
And Neil has a little bit of that, too.
尼尔也有一点这样的经历。
We had a little bit of overlap with that, too.
我们也有一些重叠。
You know, it's true.
你知道，这是真的。
I mean, a lot of writers, like Steven Sondheim very famously, was a huge crossword puzzle guy, right?
我的意思是，很多作家，比如著名的史蒂文·桑德海姆，都是一个填字游戏的大佬，对吧？
Yeah.
是的。
And I think there's something about the brain, the comedy brain, lyricist brain that when things land in the right place, it's so satisfying, right?
我认为大脑、喜剧大脑、抒情大脑有某种东西，当事情落在正确的位置时，它是如此令人满意，对吧？
There's a little bit of a puzzle to it.
这其中有一点令人困惑。
Yeah.
是的。
And, and, and thinking, thinking, yeah, certainly when you're did all sorts of things.
并且，并且，思考，思考，是的，当然当你做了各种各样的事情时。
Yeah.
是的。
When you're 15 episodes into a 22 episode season, you, it is a puzzle because you have this dictate, like, okay, we have to get the plot here.
当你在 22 集的季节里看到 15 集时，你会感到困惑，因为你有这样的指示，就像，好吧，我们必须在这里得到情节。
We have to move the plot here, but we also, we have to have it funny and it has to be self-contained.
我们必须把情节移到这里，但我们也必须让它变得有趣，而且它必须是独立的。
If you're just tuning in for this one episode, we want audiences to kind of follow it, but you also to want to reward people who've been watching from episode one, like there is a lot of puzzle making.
如果您只是收看这一集，我们希望观众能够关注它，但您也想奖励那些从第一集开始观看的人，就像有很多谜题制作一样。
And that's a huge challenge.
这是一个巨大的挑战。
Craig, I don't know how much you've talked about that, but like balancing the serialized nature of the show with the episodic nature and the show was a huge challenge in the first season.
克雷格，我不知道你对此谈了多少，但就像平衡该剧的连续性和剧集性一样，该剧在第一季是一个巨大的挑战。
And we never tried to go this deep back into somebody's past, a character's past either.
我们也从未尝试过如此深入地追溯某个人的过去，一个角色的过去。
So this episode was new.
所以这一集是新的。
We hadn't gone like this really digs into Barney 10 years prior, more, however many years prior, like we'd never done that move while also trying to establish Ted and Victoria's relationship as a moving forward.
十年前，我们还没有像这样真正深入研究过巴尼，更多的是，无论多少年前，就像我们从未做过那样的举动，同时也试图建立泰德和维多利亚的关系作为前进。
Robin, it feels weird toward Victoria.
罗宾，对维多利亚感觉很奇怪。
We need to plan some seeds of trouble for Ted and Victoria looking ahead, which this does.
我们需要为泰德和维多利亚的未来埋下一些麻烦的种子，这确实做到了。
The DNA of their breakup is written in this little teeny tiny, you know, moment in this episode.
他们分手的DNA就写在这一集的这个小小的、微小的时刻。
There was, there was a lot to do while also doing the Darth Vader story.
在制作达斯·维德的故事的同时，还有很多事情要做。
There's another thing that you guys did that I thought was really sly, which is like Marshall's clearly rigging the game to interrogate.
你们还做了另一件我认为非常狡猾的事情，就像马歇尔明显操纵游戏来审问一样。
He's the ultimate authority on Marsh Gammon.
他是马什·甘蒙的最终权威。
So people are like, okay, I guess, you know, it's the person to your left autobiography, like the switching it to always be about quizzing her.
所以人们就像，好吧，我想，你知道，这是你左边的自传中的人，就像把它切换到总是关于询问她一样。
Yeah, Chris, do you remember when you when you went off to write this episode?
是的，克里斯，你还记得你什么时候去写这一集的吗？
Was there any aspect of like, it was your feeling like we knew the Barney part would be funny, the flashbacks.
有没有什么方面，比如你的感觉，我们知道巴尼的部分会很有趣，闪回。
We knew hippie Barney would be funny.
我们知道嬉皮士巴尼会很有趣。
You know, that's the raw red meat.
你知道，那是生红肉。
And so do you almost like, you feel like, well, we got that.
所以你几乎喜欢，你觉得，好吧，我们明白了。
So I need to make sure the present day stuff is equal to that or is like moving things forward in another way.
所以我需要确保现在的事情与此相同，或者就像以另一种方式推动事情向前发展。
Like the structure of Barney demanding offerings for to unlock each new like board game level of this story.
就像巴尼的结构一样，需要提供解锁这个故事的每个新棋盘游戏级别的产品。
That's such a great structure.
这是一个非常棒的结构。
I forget who's that was and if that was yours or not, but that idea of like a need, it's a series of keys.
我忘记了那是谁，也忘记了那是不是你的，但就像需求一样，它是一系列钥匙。
It's a Sphinx kind of riddle kind of, like you have to make an offering to get to the next level.
这是一个类似狮身人面像的谜语，就像你必须提供贡品才能进入下一个级别。
And I don't know who did, I'm pretty sure I didn't because in my head, I think I would have written it much more formal and structured and not as good.
我不知道是谁写的，我很确定我没有写，因为在我看来，我认为我会写得更正式、更有条理，但不会那么好。
I think I would have written it as if, as he said, okay, if you each tell me a story that I'm going to, about your own most embarrassing moment, then I will, each time you do that then, like I would have made it a very formal thing.
我想我会这样写，就像他说的那样，好吧，如果你们每个人都给我讲一个故事，关于你们自己最尴尬的时刻，那么我会的，每次你们这样做时，就像我会把它变成一件非常正式的事情一样。
And in the episode, it comes out very organically.
在这一集中，它的表现非常自然。
Like the first one is just Barney saying no, I don't want to do it.
就像第一个只是巴尼说不，我不想这样做。
and and Marshall sort of stepping forward voluntarily.
马歇尔有点自愿地走上前去。
It felt it felt much better.
感觉这样的感觉好多了。
So I think I know that that was part of the breaking of the story was like, oh, each, yeah, each person makes an offering and and and Barney rewards that offering with another piece of his of his story.
所以我想我知道这是故事的一部分，就像，哦，每个人，是的，每个人都做出贡献，巴尼用他的故事的另一部分来奖励这个贡献。
But I yeah, it definitely was a group effort there, I'm sure.
但我是的，我确信这绝对是团队的努力。
We talked about also how I met your mother.
我们还谈到了我是如何认识你母亲的。
It was 2005, 2006, this first season.
那是2005年、2006年，这是第一季。
It was almost like the first time it was appropriate to parody the 90s or look at the 90s as a period piece.
这几乎就像第一次适合戏仿 90 年代或将 90 年代视为时代作品。
Like I really think it wasn't, we weren't, it was like, oh, can we do that?
就像我真的认为这不是，我们不是，就像，哦，我们能做到吗？
Like it still felt like we had one foot in the 90s, but there was enough, there was just enough distance for it to look like, what was the, what are the things called the, like, the, what are the, what are the things called?
感觉仍然像我们的一只脚在 90 年代，但已经足够了，有足够的距离让它看起来像，什么是，这些东西叫什么，就像，这个，什么是，这些东西叫什么？
Did they have a name?
他们有名字吗？
Ah, it's a great question, but they were everywhere.
啊，这是一个很好的问题，但它们无处不在。
Everywhere.
到处。
And I will say that watching it is like, I couldn't believe how much.
我想说的是，观看它就像是，我简直不敢相信。
I mean, that was one great thing about the show, is everyone in every department went all in.
我的意思是，这个节目的一大优点是每个部门的每个人都全力以赴。
The wardrobe was amazing.
衣柜很棒。
So good.
超好的。
That bar was amazing.
那个酒吧太棒了。
Baja hoodie.
巴哈连帽衫。
Yeah, oh, baja hoodie.
是的，哦，巴哈连帽衫。
Oh, fantastic.
哦，太棒了。
Every guy, there was like 20 of those guys, every guy, that guy in every college, right in the 90s, that was totally.
每个人，大约有 20 个这样的人，每个人，每个大学里的那个人，就在 90 年代，完全是这样。
I think it was a baja hoodie.
我认为这是一件巴哈连帽衫。
Though I do see an alternate of drug rug.
虽然我确实看到了毒品地毯的替代品。
Drug rug, okay.
毒品地毯，好吧。
Drug rug.
毒品地毯。
He's, Neil, the hair and makeup was amazing, the wardrobe was amazing.
他，尼尔，发型和妆容都很棒，衣柜也很棒。
And his physicalization, Neil's physical take on that character, he became a different human being.
而他的身体化，尼尔对这个角色的身体呈现，他变成了一个不同的人。
His body was completely different.
他的身体完全不同了。
It was so good.
真是太好了。
And his every expression and every molecule of him was a different guy, it was so well done.
他的每一个表情、每一个分子都是一个不同的人，做得太好了。
I also, I also had forgotten Katie Walden, that's who played Shannon.
我也，我也忘记了扮演香农的凯蒂·瓦尔登。
Yeah.
是的。
She was so good.
她太好了。
She's really good.
她真的很好。
Yeah.
是的。
She also had that transformation that she had to do too.
她也有她必须要做的转变。
Yeah.
是的。
back in in that red, like power suit kind of corporate outfit, it's so great.
回到那红色，就像权力套装那种公司服装，太棒了。
I forgot that she says legendary to she's the was she I forgot that you had her say legendary we threw every origin story that we could and it's amazing that it was like only 15 episodes in how much we had okay we got sued up we're gonna throw in there with legendary high five I mean it's basically like that first opening sequence of the third Indiana Jones where they're just like the It was totally that, it was totally that.
我忘了她对她说“传奇”，我忘了你让她说“传奇”，我们尽我们所能地讲述了每一个起源故事，令人惊奇的是，这就像只有15集一样，我们已经被起诉了，我们要在那里投入传奇的高五我的意思是，这基本上就像第三部印第安纳琼斯的第一个开场序列，他们就像“完全就是那样，完全就是那样”。
I also thought, this is a shout out to casting.
我还想，这是对选角的呼喊。
The guy who plays the suit guy, who he mistakes for her father, was like really perfectly cast, because he has to be plausible, both as someone Barney could look at and go, oh, this guy has something figured out.
扮演西装男的那个人，他误以为是她的父亲，他的演员阵容真的很完美，因为他必须是可信的，既是巴尼可以看到的人，又可以说，哦，这个家伙已经想出了一些办法。
And also from the back, he's like, he looks older.
而且从背面看，他看起来更老了。
Like it was a deft kind of casting bit, I thought.
我想，这就像一种灵巧的铸造技巧。
Craig, can I ask, did you know before the show started, roughly what Barney's origin story was or just did you decide you needed one and it was in this room that you figured it out?
克雷格，我能问一下，你在节目开始之前知道巴尼的起源故事大致是什么吗？或者你只是决定需要一个故事，而你就是在这个房间里想出来的？
I think we knew he was a very different guy at some point.
我想我们知道他在某个时候是一个非常不同的人。
The specificity of making him that much of a hippie and like just allowing ourselves to be kids in a candy store with those jokes, Chris.
克里斯，这种特殊性让他变得如此嬉皮士，就像让我们自己像糖果店里的孩子一样，开着这些笑话。
I feel like that we found in the room, right?
我感觉就像我们在房间里找到的一样，对吧？
Because I think he said he wasn't this guy, he was sensitive, he had his heart broken, something made.
因为我认为他说他不是这个人，他很敏感，他的心都碎了，有些东西是人造的。
He was Anakin Skywalker before Emperor Palpatine.
他是帕尔帕廷皇帝之前的阿纳金·天行者。
It's like dragged him in.
就好像把他拉进去一样。
Totally.
完全。
But I think the specificity of getting him that hippie-ish and allowing ourselves to push it a little bit, that came from the right side.
但我认为让他变得嬉皮士风格并让我们自己推动它一点点的特殊性来自正确的一面。
And it was so fun.
这太有趣了。
It was so fun.
太有趣了。
Yeah.
是的。
I don't give high fives, I only give high twos.
我不会击掌，我只会击掌。
Yeah.
是的。
Was that you, Chris, high twos?
克里斯，那是你吗？
I'd like to think it was.
我想是的。
But it was It was basically, let's collect all these cliches and all these twists on who Barney is versus who he was.
但基本上，让我们收集所有这些陈词滥调以及所有这些关于巴尼是谁与他是谁的曲折。
And like you said, it was a candy store because there was so much to work with.
就像你说的，这是一家糖果店，因为有很多事情需要处理。
And yeah, and then watching Neil embody it was just insane.
是的，然后看着尼尔的表现真是太疯狂了。
I forget, was it in the script or was it a Neil choice to call it Niharaq?
我忘了，是在剧本里还是尼尔选择将其称为“Niharaq”？
Oh, that was Neil.
哦，那是尼尔。
That was Neil.
那是尼尔.
Yeah, that was so funny.
是的，那太有趣了。
Just going for it, getting away with it.
只是去追求它，摆脱它。
As I recall, he was super sick, for at least part of the taping.
我记得，他病得很重，至少在录音的一部分时间里是这样。
Like, I remember he had the flu or something and was just like convalescing in between takes, but then would just sort of bring it in and bring it out.
就像，我记得他得了流感什么的，就像在两次拍摄之间康复一样，但随后就会把它带进来然后带出来。
He was devastated about Shannon.
他对香农感到非常震惊。
It makes sense.
这是有道理的。
I know.
我知道。
It really helps his devastation and like crying and looking all, like, fucked up, but he's not even crying.
这确实帮助了他的毁灭，就像哭了一样，看起来很糟糕，但他甚至没有哭。
That moment when you see that tape first and he's a hippie, it is such information over when you see, you barely recognize him.
当你第一次看到那盘磁带时，他是个嬉皮士，当你看到这些信息时，你几乎认不出他了。
He's a hippie, he's at a piano, his hair's long, he's got the shitty soul batch, and he's singing a song and crying.
他是个嬉皮士，他在钢琴前，他的头发很长，他有一批糟糕的灵魂，他一边唱着歌一边哭。
It's so in the deep end right away, you're just jumping into the deep end.
马上就进入了深渊，你只是跳进了深渊。
When you hear Shannon gave me a tape, and he freaks out, you're like certain it's a sex tape.
当你听到香农给了我一盘磁带，他吓坏了，你就可以肯定这是一盘性爱录像带。
It's gotta be a sex tape.
这一定是性爱录像带。
An embarrassing one, because otherwise he'd be black.
这是一件令人尴尬的事，否则他就会变成黑人。
And not his best work.
而且不是他最好的作品。
It's not his best work.
这不是他最好的作品。
That's it, because the reaction of freaking out about that tape, and then trying to be casual.
就是这样，因为对那盘磁带感到害怕的反应，然后试图变得随意。
It's so funny.
太搞笑了。
And they're nice, like.
他们很好，就像。
Where's the tape?
磁带在哪里？
I love where's the tape, but Lily's switcheroo on him, like I thought this might have.
我喜欢磁带在哪里，但莉莉对他的态度发生了变化，就像我想的那样。
Oh, I also agree with that.
哦，我也同意这一点。
So I gave two-tenths graduation.
所以我给了十分之二的毕业。
That's also a great level of love.
这也是一种高度的爱。
That's revealing of Lily's kind of forethought, like knowing Barney.
这揭示了莉莉的深谋远虑，就像认识巴尼一样。
It's reveal of Barney his thing in the episode.
巴尼在这一集中透露了他的事情。
And it's also like, it's revealing of Ted, like, he's sentimental, he wants his graduation day, like, now it's destroyed, you know?
这也像是，它揭示了特德，就像，他是多愁善感的，他想要他的毕业典礼，就像，现在它被毁了，你知道吗？
You're right, it's like a threefer, right?
你说得对，这就像三人行一样，对吧？
If it was somebody else, they wouldn't care.
如果是别人，他们也不会在意。
If it was, it was Robin's graduate, who cares?
如果是的话，那是罗宾的毕业生，谁在乎呢？
But Ted, you could just see, and just that it's just a one little quick shot of him.
但是特德，你可以看到，这只是他的一个小镜头。
The wounded, double taking.
受伤者，双倍接受。
Yeah, yeah.
是啊是啊。
And he can't do anything about it, yeah.
他对此无能为力，是的。
Who would have written this song?
谁会写这首歌？
Cause I know Craig, you and Carter usually were doing it.
因为我知道克雷格，你和卡特通常都是这样做的。
We didn't write that.
我们没有写那个。
Chris, I think Chris just wrote funny lyrics and our wonderful composer, John Swahart, Yeah, would have put me easy to that one, that was not us.
克里斯，我认为克里斯只是写了有趣的歌词，而我们出色的作曲家约翰·斯瓦哈特，是的，会让我轻松地唱出那首歌，那不是我们。
I think it was written in the room.
我想这是在房间里写的。
And I honestly, I think Sparkhart did an amazing job.
老实说，我认为 Sparkhart 做得非常出色。
I don't know if we took the care that we learned that we could and the fun that we had writing, like later songs, we just spent, you just got slapped and super, like it was so fun to do every single lyric.
我不知道我们是否注意到了我们学到的能力以及我们写作时的乐趣，就像后来的歌曲一样，我们只是花了，你只是被打了一巴掌，超级，就像做每一个歌词都很有趣。
And here I think, I don't know if we were under the gun or not, but yeah, we just wrote it.
我想，我不知道我们是否处于枪口之下，但是，是的，我们只是写了它。
There's something a little bit of that song.
这首歌里有一点点东西。
I feel like later we would have like put out the full like three million version of that.
我觉得稍后我们会推出完整的 300 万个版本。
So we didn't realize that move yet.
所以我们还没有意识到这一举动。
You would have set up a website with a couple with a series of songs.
您可能会建立一个由一对夫妇提供一系列歌曲的网站。
The album he made for him.
他为他制作的专辑。
We missed a big bet there for sure.
我们肯定错过了那里的一个大赌注。
Chris, do you know what else I was thinking about the structure of this one that I loved?
克里斯，你知道我对我喜欢的这个结构的结构还有什么看法吗？
I remember it feeling like, how do we make the present day move, right?
我记得当时的感觉是，我们如何推动当今时代的发展，对吧？
We were talking about that earlier, but at the dilemma of how do you, you can't just have it be a clip show, you need stuff happening in the present.
我们之前讨论过这一点，但在如何做的困境中，你不能只是让它成为一个剪辑节目，你需要现在发生的事情。
I love that the end of the story happens tonight, where we catch up to the present day and Barney actually.
我喜欢故事的结局发生在今晚，我们实际上赶上了今天和巴尼。
And we remember we felt that important that he had taken a video, so it was clear he really had done this, this was not invented.
我们记得我们觉得他拍摄了一段视频很重要，所以很明显他确实做到了这一点，这不是发明的。
Totally.
完全。
The idea that the story ends, the story begins in 1997, whenever it begins, and it ends like a half hour before he started the story in the bar.
故事结束的想法，故事从1997年开始，无论什么时候开始，都结束了，就像他在酒吧开始故事之前的半个小时一样。
That was, I feel like that unlocked it because it literally connected the past story to tonight, literally tonight.
那是，我觉得这解锁了它，因为它确实将过去的故事与今晚联系起来，确实是今晚。
I remember that being a moment of breaking the story, I feel like this will work.
我记得那是一个打破这个故事的时刻，我觉得这会起作用。
And I definitely don't take credit for that.
我绝对不会因此而居功。
That was definitely either you or Carter, but the, yeah, I remember thinking about it and seeing like, oh, he couldn't have done the video evidence a few years earlier.
那肯定是你或卡特，但是，是的，我记得考虑过这一点，然后发现，哦，他不可能在几年前完成视频证据。
Like that's how new the phone, you can see by the phone.
就像手机有多新一样，你可以通过手机看到。
If I could do it once.
如果我能做一次就好了。
It's not free, yeah, or something I'd feel like that.
它不是免费的，是的，或者我感觉那样的东西。
Also, we're doing a little bit on Chris on the show of atonement for things that were perhaps ill-advised.
此外，我们还在克里斯身上做一些事情，以弥补那些可能是不明智的事情。
I'm pretty sure that's like a felony.
我很确定这就像重罪。
Yeah, you know what I mean?
是的，你知道我的意思吗？
That is definitely, you can't do that.
那是肯定的，你不能这样做。
Yeah, you can't do that.
是的，你不能那样做。
Oh, there's plenty to atone for.
哦，有很多东西需要赎罪。
I mean, yeah, there's the, I won't get into specifics, but yeah, there are times when I've been watching with my kids and I'm just, oh.
我的意思是，是的，有，我不会透露具体细节，但是，是的，有时我和我的孩子们一起看，我只是，哦。
Yeah, that's not the best.
是的，这不是最好的。
But it's also like you keep expecting, and this is, this is Neil so good at the fake, like he's so good at playing one thing and then pulling the rug out from under it, but you keep expecting like some sort of self-reflection that brings him back to a place like the basic human decency, And he always doubles down on like, I'm making the right choice.
但这也就像你一直在期待，这是尼尔如此擅长假装，就像他很擅长玩一件事，然后把地毯从它下面拉出来，但你一直期待某种自我反省，让他回到像基本人类尊严这样的地方，他总是加倍努力，我正在做出正确的选择。
Wearing suits and sleeping with tons of women and saying, it's like the choice is the way to be.
穿着西装，和很多女人一起睡觉，并说，这就像选择就是应该的方式。
It looks, yeah, it looks like he's having that moment and then he just sort of looks up and it's that 180.
看起来，是的，看起来他正在享受那一刻，然后他抬起头，发现就是那个 180 度。
He's a bit of the Seinfeld dictate, you know, no hugging, no learning.
你知道，他有点像宋飞传，没有拥抱，没有学习。
Like Neil for a long time is no hugging, no learning.
就像尼尔一样，很长一段时间没有拥抱，没有学习。
Yes.
是的。
But in his own bubble because, but on the show itself, like I watching it last night, I was like, oh, he's totally broken.
但在他自己的泡沫中，因为，但在节目本身上，就像我昨晚看的那样，我当时想，哦，他完全崩溃了。
He's totally, he's totally, that's my defense of all this.
他完全，他完全，这就是我对这一切的辩护。
He thinks he's awesome, but he's clearly going through some stuff.
他认为自己很棒，但显然他正在经历一些事情。
Obviously, Shannon wasn't that much of a villain, but that's what he's gotten his head about all women.
显然，香农并不是那么坏人，但这就是他对所有女人的看法。
And he's, I don't know, I felt, I felt closer to almost Lily's view of him by the end of watching it this time around.
而他，我不知道，我感觉，我感觉在这次观看结束时，我感觉更接近莉莉对他的看法。
And I'm not sure, I'm not sure what I remember thinking.
我不确定，我不确定我记得在想什么。
Everything Barney does comes out of hurt and scars and being broken, every single thing he does.
巴尼所做的每一件事都源于伤害、伤疤和破碎，他所做的每一件事。
And a lot of what he does, he makes up and he didn't really do.
他所做的很多事情都是他编造出来的，但他并没有真正做过。
We felt it important this one that he had some evidence that he had actually have to understand and because even he realized how far that should sound, it is not the best move that a guy could do, that's for sure, it's the worst thing.
我们认为这一点很重要，他有一些证据表明他实际上必须理解，因为即使他意识到这听起来应该有多远，这也不是一个人可以做的最好的举动，这是肯定的，这是最糟糕的事情。
But it comes from being broken.
但它来自于破碎。
One of the meta questions of the show is like, how reliable is the show based on its older Ted narrating this?
该节目的元问题之一是，该节目基于老泰德的叙述有多可靠？
But are we watching the real thing that happened?
但我们看到的是真实发生的事情吗？
Or are we watching older Ted's version and somewhat sanitized version of the thing that happened for his to tell his children.
或者我们是在看老泰德的版本，以及他告诉他的孩子们所发生的事情的经过某种净化的版本。
In the same way in this episode, you could question like, how much of the, like Barney's telling the story.
同样，在这一集中，你可能会问，有多少像巴尼讲的故事。
And I totally questioned it probably even more than when we shot it as I was watching it last night was like, obviously she's not coming in suddenly like, I've totally changed because I met one.
我完全质疑它可能比我们拍摄它时还要多，因为我昨晚看它就像，显然她不会突然进来，就像，我完全改变了，因为我遇到了一个。
I don't know, it just felt like it was Barney's view of this woman as opposed to what actually happened.
我不知道，只是感觉这只是巴尼对这个女人的看法，而不是实际发生的事情。
Yeah.
是的。
I was fascinating.
我很着迷。
In an earlier draft, he slept with her mother instead of her.
在早期的草稿中，他和她的母亲而不是她一起睡。
I don't know why, I think cutting out the middle name was better.
我不知道为什么，我认为去掉中间名更好。
Yeah, they're always like a little- That guy got in the draft?
是的，他们总是像个小——那个家伙参加了选秀？
Like he wrote that- It got into at least an outline.
就像他写的那样——至少有一个大纲。
At least an outline?
至少有一个大纲吧？
Yeah, it's all the crazy dead ends and things.
是的，这都是疯狂的死胡同之类的。
No, no, no, just have him sleep with her.
不不不，就让他陪她睡吧。
Yeah, right, he's there.
是的，没错，他就在那里。
It has to be that.
一定是这样。
He's Barney.
他是巴尼。
Yeah.
是的。
I really like the line, Ted's line.
我真的很喜欢这句话，特德的台词。
You guys have been like the parents I still have and moved here to get away from.
你们就像我的父母一样，搬到这里是为了逃离。
I like that line.
我喜欢那条线。
That's a Chris Harris line, for sure.
这肯定是克里斯·哈里斯的台词。
That's a great line.
这是一条很棒的线。
It feels like it feels like it's got a little bit clever.
给人的感觉就是有点小聪明的感觉。
It's very clever.
这非常聪明。
Punch up to it.
冲上去吧。
Yeah.
是的。
It's much too long for what someone would say in reality in that moment.
对于现实中某人在那一刻所说的话来说太长了。
So, yes, I agree.
所以，是的，我同意。
That's what it does.
这就是它的作用。
I also loved Robin's switch on Prudelert, slut alert.
我也喜欢罗宾对普鲁德勒特的转变，荡妇警报。
Yeah, that's correct.
是的，这是正确的。
That's correct.
这是正确的。
I don't remember anything.
我什么都不记得了。
I think I was drunk for a lot of this.
我想我喝醉了很多次。
I love, Neil does so many like little subtle, crazy things, but his trembling lower lip in the video.
我喜欢尼尔做了很多像微妙的、疯狂的事情，但视频中他的下唇颤抖着。
The trembling lower lip is unbelievable.
颤抖的下唇令人难以置信。
It's unbelievable.
真是难以置信。
It's literally like a ballet dancer of a face.
它实际上就像一个芭蕾舞演员的脸。
Like how does he even, he has such like, technical control of his instrument, like just all physically.
就像他是如何做到的，他对他的乐器有这样的技术控制，就像所有的身体控制一样。
I've always managed.
我一直都做到了。
I rewound and rewatched that.
我倒带并重新看了一遍。
I watched it twice last night watching it because I couldn't believe it.
昨晚我看了两遍，因为我简直不敢相信。
It was, I had forgotten how insane that adventure was.
是的，我已经忘记了那次冒险是多么疯狂。
And it's the goatee going.
这是山羊胡。
And this old man, he musted me, fell in love with you, knew who you were sitting.
这位老人，他必须我，爱上了你，知道你坐在谁的身边。
And now, commercials, end of commercials, back to shell.
现在，广告，广告结束，回到外壳。
I heard Martin Short say something years ago that always stayed with me.
几年前，我听到马丁·肖特说过一句话，至今让我印象深刻。
He said, the cliche about theater acting is you need to be as big as you can.
他说，关于戏剧表演的陈词滥调是你需要尽可能大。
And the cliche about film acting is to be as small as you can.
关于电影表演的陈词滥调就是要尽可能小。
He says, I think of it as the reverse.
他说，我认为恰恰相反。
in the theater, you're trying to be as subtle as you can and still get it to the back row.
在剧院里，你会尽你所能地保持微妙，但仍然能把它带到后排。
Whereas in film, you wanna be as big and expressive as you can without being too big for the camera, for the lens, right?
而在电影中，你想要尽可能大和富有表现力，但又不想对相机、镜头来说太大，对吗？
And I really think like Neil is a master at scale.
我真的认为尼尔是规模方面的大师。
Like he knows, like if he knows when the camera's back and he, like one of the great, I think, physical comedy things I've ever seen was Neil after running the marathon trying to stand on this subway.
就像他知道一样，就像他知道摄像机什么时候回来一样，我认为，我见过的最伟大的肢体喜剧之一是尼尔跑完马拉松后试图站在地铁上。
Oh my God, I'm trying to stand it down.
天哪，我正在努力忍住。
Like it's an unbelievable physical comedian feet, right?
就像喜剧演员的脚令人难以置信，对吧？
But I also think he knew like when the camera was super up close on him He knew how to give the trembling lip in such a way that it's it can hold the camera can hold it, you know?
但我也认为他知道当相机离他非常近时他知道如何以这样的方式给出颤抖的嘴唇，这样它就可以容纳相机可以容纳它，你知道吗？
Yeah, yeah, it's fantastic And his walk just his walk across that cafe like his is just So specific and weird and different just showed he revolutionized his entire personality Like, there wasn't a thing about himself that he didn't throw out and start over again as New Barney.
是的，是的，这太棒了，他的步行就像他穿过那家咖啡馆一样，是如此具体、奇怪和不同，这表明他彻底改变了他的整个个性就像，他没有抛弃自己的一切，重新以新巴尼的身份重新开始。
Yes.
是的。
And of course I remember your story that in his audition, he did a somersault.
当然，我记得你的故事，在他的试镜中，他翻了跟头。
Yes.
是的。
I mean, the physical comedy was part of it from the beginning.
我的意思是，肢体喜剧从一开始就是其中的一部分。
Literally from the audition, he was doing like shoulder rolls across like people's like casting directors, you know, offices.
从试镜的字面上看，他的动作就像选角导演一样，你知道，办公室。
Do you remember him being super game to do this, Chris?
克里斯，你还记得他在这件事上表现得非常出色吗？
Do you remember like, was this like getting the candy store for him too, was he like?
你还记得吗，这就像给他买了一家糖果店一样，是吗？
He was really, he was really excited.
他真的、他真的很兴奋。
And you could tell there's so many little, just him kicking the trash can when he's upset walking down the street.
你可以看出有很多小事，只有他心烦意乱地走在街上时踢垃圾桶。
And hurting his foot, hurting his foot.
还伤了他的脚，伤了他的脚。
And that lasts for a few steps.
这持续了几步。
He was, he took it as the gift that we were helping.
他是，他认为这是我们正在帮助的礼物。
The crying, and when that sequence begins and that sort of semi Darth Vader music kind of kicks in and takes in that sequence, that you know you're really in for the ride at that point.
哭泣，当那个序列开始时，那种半达斯·维达的音乐开始出现并融入那个序列，你知道你真的在那个时候开始了。
Like that's such a satisfying moment when that sequence begins.
当这个序列开始时，那是一个令人满足的时刻。
It's like, this whole episode has been leading to this.
就好像，整个事件都导致了这一点。
This is gonna work.
这会起作用的。
And the idea to play that all in that kind of white limbo space is really avant-garde and weird.
在那种白色的边缘空间中演奏这一切的想法真的很前卫和奇怪。
Do you remember how we quite got, it's because it was the Darth Vader thing, which was kind of an important thing.
你还记得我们是怎么做到的吗，因为这是达斯·维德的事情，这是一件很重要的事情。
It's almost like the return of the shirt montage.
这几乎就像衬衫蒙太奇的回归。
It's like things that you can't do when there's 200 people on, you know, high on candy in a live taping.
这就像当有 200 个人在现场录音中享受糖果时你无法做的事情。
Like that is where the cow and the mother became like this weird cinematic hybrid of, you know, a sitcom, a classic sitcom with like all these cinematic elements.
就像那样，牛和母亲就变成了这种奇怪的电影混合体，你知道，一部情景喜剧，一部带有所有这些电影元素的经典情景喜剧。
Yeah, yeah.
是啊是啊。
And no idea where that white background came from, but it was awesome.
不知道那个白色背景是从哪里来的，但它太棒了。
And then John Swire, the composer, just doing that perfect sort of, boom, boom, boom, boom.
然后作曲家约翰·施怀尔（John Swire）就开始完美地演奏着，繁荣，繁荣，繁荣，繁荣。
Just caring, you know exactly what you're watching.
只要关心，你就知道自己在看什么。
I also liked how the suit was all dark, like an all black suit, basically.
我也喜欢这套衣服是全黑的，基本上就像全黑套装一样。
Never would have said that, but never would have chosen that, but it's great.
从来不会这么说，也永远不会选择那样，但这很棒。
It's so Darth Vader.
这太达斯·维达了。
It's the suit Darth Vader would wear.
这是达斯维德穿的衣服。
Speaking of clothes, this is a silly throwaway.
说到衣服，这是一种愚蠢的一次性行为。
I really like Marshall sweater.
我真的很喜欢马歇尔毛衣。
With a dog though.
虽然带着狗。
With a little orange dog.
带着一只橙色的小狗。
I did have a moment where I said, what's happening?
我确实曾经说过，发生了什么事？
Was that dog?
那是狗吗？
I forgot to swear to the dog.
我忘了向狗发誓。
I like it.
我喜欢它。
I thought it was cool.
我觉得这很酷。
I thought it was better than in my house.
我觉得比我家的好。
Oh, really?
哦真的吗？
I'm pro.
我是专业人士。
I'm team Marshall sweater.
我是马歇尔队毛衣。
Fantastic drunk, Josh.
喝醉了，乔什。
And I mean that in the most respectful way.
我的意思是以最尊重的方式。
That is really hard to do.
这确实很难做到。
With just going back to the re-return.
刚回去就重新返回。
I forgot how big, that's a big deal that we revealed that too, that he re-returned that night of the pilot.
我忘了有多大，这是一件大事，我们也透露了这一点，他在飞行员的那天晚上重新返回了。
And then we dive back into the pilot.
然后我们回到试播集。
I was like, fuck, I forgot that we also do that in this episode, like it's sort of like, do you know what I was hooked on?
我当时想，操，我忘了我们在这一集里也这么做了，就像是，你知道我着迷的是什么吗？
There's a lot behind here.
这里后面有很多东西。
I was like, they've been drinking a lot in this bar, including Ranjit, who then drives that.
我当时想，他们在这家酒吧喝了很多酒，包括兰吉特，然后他开车。
I was like, wait a minute, this can't be safe, that is a great observation, maybe that's a good dream.
我当时想，等一下，这不安全，这是一个很好的观察，也许这是一个好梦。
Another Atonement session, I guess.
我猜又是一次赎罪会议。
Don't drink and drive, kids.
孩子们，不要酒后驾车。
Don't drink and drive.
不要酒后驾车。
Don't film people without them knowing.
不要在别人不知情的情况下拍摄他们。
There's a lot of things to not do on this show.
在这个节目中有很多事情不能做。
Do you know what?
你知道什么吗？
I mean, there's so many little funny things, and I mean, the white is so funny, but I loved.
我的意思是，有很多有趣的小事情，我的意思是，白色很有趣，但我喜欢。
We're not quitting just because Ted's so far ahead.
我们不会仅仅因为特德遥遥领先而放弃。
And he says, I was winning.
他说，我赢了。
I was winning.
我赢了。
Like, no one has any idea how to play this game, except Marshall, which is probably not even a real game, but that made me laugh.
就像，除了马歇尔之外，没有人知道如何玩这个游戏，这可能甚至不是一个真正的游戏，但这让我笑了。
The idea that there's mayonnaise and the cookies.
有蛋黄酱和饼干的想法。
I mean, we're playing off the seven layer salad a little bit there.
我的意思是，我们正在玩七层沙拉。
We're kind of calling it.
我们有点这么称呼它。
She puts mayonnaise and everything and she misses mayonnaise with sweet dishes.
她放了蛋黄酱和所有东西，她想念蛋黄酱和甜食。
The slide in of Marshall's mom is fantastic.
马歇尔妈妈的滑入太棒了。
Just dying inside.
简直要死在里面了。
Yeah.
是的。
That was so good.
那太好了。
Well, I just thought also this episode is a little bit like, there's got to be a term for it.
好吧，我只是觉得这一集有点像，必须有一个术语来形容它。
I call it like filling in the lore, but it's like how I met everyone else.
我称之为填充传说，但这就像我如何认识其他人一样。
Remember that episode?
还记得那一集吗？
Yeah.
是的。
Like just, you know, you guys created a show, Craig, that had such an ability to make so many different moves.
就像，你知道，你们创造了一个节目，克雷格，它有能力做出这么多不同的动作。
You could zip forward, you could zip back, you could forget a piece of information, go, oh, I forgot to tell you this part.
你可以向前移动，你可以向后移动，你可以忘记一条信息，走吧，哦，我忘了告诉你这一部分。
Like, you really granted yourself like a real superpower narratively.
就像，你真的把自己当作一个真正的超级大国。
This episode had more of them than I remembered.
这一集的内容比我记得的还要多。
Like, Victoria's being omitted and just cutting the black screen.
就像，维多利亚被忽略了，只是剪掉了黑屏。
You know, that was great.
你知道，那太棒了。
Right, right.
对，对。
And that was out of necessity, I really, because I saw, I found a story that she told, and deep in a, again, like, Oh wow.
那是出于必要，我真的，因为我看到了，我发现了她讲的一个故事，并且深深地，再次，就像，哦哇。
In the cobwebs of my map, of my Mac.
在我的地图、我的 Mac 的蜘蛛网中。
And it was okay.
没关系。
It was okay.
So this was much better then.
所以这在当时要好得多。
It's much better to not say it.
最好还是不要说出来。
Much better to just not say it.
So it was born of a necessity.
所以它的诞生是出于一种需要。
But yeah, I feel like this was something, I think that's super power, Josh, that you talk about is really cool, because I think in later episodes and seasons, the storytelling, there was a little bit more discovery.
但是，是的，我觉得这就是某种东西，我认为这就是超级力量，乔什，你谈论的真的很酷，因为我认为在后来的剧集和季节中，讲故事，有更多的发现。
Oh, here's what we can do.
哦，这就是我们能做的。
And you look at trilogy time.
你看看三部曲的时间。
You look at Harry Met everyone else.
你看看哈利遇见了其他人。
You look at all these other flashback and ways that flashbacks and flash forward were used.
您会看到所有其他闪回以及使用闪回和闪进的方式。
The one where Saggot or where Olderted completely gets every moment wrong and can't remember things.
萨戈特或奥尔德泰德每时每刻都完全出错并且不记得事情。
And I feel like this was just us still in the shallow end almost, but having a lot of fun as we're discovering it.
我觉得这只是我们还处于浅水区，但在我们发现它的过程中享受到了很多乐趣。
I mean, there's a funny, I'm always struck by how invested Lily and Marshall are, especially in the early seasons in Ted and his lore and being a part of his story and getting him partnered off so they can be on that front porch together, which they haven't even talked about, but it's clearly at play.
我的意思是，有一个有趣的是，我总是对莉莉和马歇尔的投入感到震惊，尤其是在泰德和他的传说的早期几季中，成为他故事的一部分，让他搭档，这样他们就可以一起站在前廊上，他们甚至没有谈论过这一点，但这显然在发挥作用。
And Marshall's hurt over, I thought you were vomit-free.
马歇尔受伤了，我以为你没有呕吐。
Like you're not, you weren't- Oh my God, the betrayal of three.
就好像你不是，你不是——天啊，三个人的背叛。
It was a discussion in the room, as I recall, like, but wait, we can't tell the story because Ted has vomit-free since 90s.
我记得，这是在房间里进行的讨论，但是等等，我们不能讲这个故事，因为特德自 90 年代以来就没有呕吐。
Is that funny that that's your grown-up professional job sitting around with other grown-ups?
与其他成年人坐在一起，这是你成年人的专业工作，这很有趣吗？
Like, no, we established that he was vomit-free since 93.
就像，不，我们确定他从 93 岁起就没有呕吐过。
Sorry.
对不起。
We can't possibly...
我们不可能...
How do we get around this?
我们如何解决这个问题？
This is just for people who love the blooper reel, but I remember I could not say the green testicle story thing.
这只是为了那些喜欢花环卷轴的人，但我记得我不能说绿色睾丸的故事。
Like on the blooper reel, there's like, I say it like five times in the wrong way.
就像在花絮卷轴上一样，我以错误的方式说了五次。
Like, I keep saying the wrong way.
就像，我总是说错话。
What got you about it?
是什么让你这么做的？
When did you start laughing?
你什么时候开始笑的？
You just got wrong.
你刚刚错了。
I kept saying testicle in the wrong place.
我一直说睾丸在错误的地方。
Is it green testicle?
睾丸是绿色的吗？
Is that the thing?
是这样的事吗？
Green testicle.
绿色睾丸。
Green testicle, yeah.
绿色睾丸，是的。
I want to get that story.
我想得到那个故事。
Someone who knows the blooper reel better than I do will have to look at season one bloopers.
比我更了解花絮卷轴的人将不得不看看第一季的花絮。
Yeah.
是的。
That's from, I didn't tell, I didn't do the ultimate frisbee part, I think was, was either room or you Craig.
那是因为，我没有告诉，我没有做最后的飞盘部分，我想，要么是房间，要么是你，克雷格。
Green testicles literally from a guy in my freshman dorm who had a, like a herniated test icle stuff like that and went into the, went into the, the health clinic and said, it's okay if we have to remove it, it's fine, you got another one and we can just replace, we You can just insert a green sphere into there, and then your life will be totally normal.
绿色睾丸确实来自我一年级宿舍里的一个人，他有一个像突出的睾丸之类的东西，然后走进健康诊所，说，如果我们必须去除它，没关系，没关系，你有另一个，我们可以更换，我们可以在其中插入一个绿色球体，然后你的生活就会完全正常。
And he says he was so horrified and shocked that all I could think of to say was, do you have any other colors?
他说他非常害怕和震惊，我只想说，你还有其他颜色吗？
Yeah.
是的。
Oh my God, I forgot that completely.
天哪，我完全忘记了。
That is the green testicle story.
这就是绿色睾丸的故事。
I couldn't remember that.
我不记得了。
Isn't it also so great?
是不是也这么厉害呢？
Like obviously your comedic sensibility, your sense of structure, like all of that is a talent.
显然，你的喜剧敏感性、你的结构感，就像所有这些都是一种天赋。
That's part of why you're in a writer's room on a great show.
这就是为什么你会在作家的房间里观看一场精彩的演出。
But also, every little weird thing that happened in your life might be admissible.
而且，你生活中发生的每一件奇怪的小事都可能是可以接受的。
It can get on to TV.
它可以上电视。
I love it.
我喜欢它。
Yeah.
是的。
Do you know what I mean?
你知道我的意思吗？
Yeah.
是的。
Like, it's just like a collection of like, throw your best stories in the pot here.
就像，它就像一个集合，把你最好的故事扔到这里。
I thought that was an invented funny phrase, Chris.
我认为这是一个发明的有趣短语，克里斯。
I forgot that that really happened.
我忘记了那件事真的发生过。
Now I'm sitting here going, did they really cut out as testicle?
现在我坐在这里想，他们真的是作为睾丸被切掉的吗？
Because he was like, he must have come out of that with two testicles.
因为他想，他一定是带着两个睾丸出来的。
I'm thinking, right?
我在想，对吗？
He did.
他做到了。
It ended up being okay.
结果还好。
That was a scare.
那是一个恐惧。
It was just a scare.
这只是一个惊吓。
But I forgot that was real.
但我忘了那是真实的。
That's amazing.
太棒了。
part of one of the best parts of doing what we do in general is like we get to share our favorite stories or our silliest ideas with others hopefully to entertain them and yeah anytime we draw from real life you know it's a good sign because if we're still remembering it then it's got the emotion that it's also like something humiliating gets repurposed for joy so it's like nothing is is wasted, do you know what I mean?
我们所做的事情中最好的部分之一就是我们可以与他人分享我们最喜欢的故事或我们最愚蠢的想法，希望能够取悦他们，是的，每当我们从现实生活中汲取灵感时，你都知道这是一个好兆头，因为如果我们仍然记得它，那么它就会有一种情感，那就是它也就像一些令人羞辱的东西被重新利用为快乐，所以就好像没有什么是浪费的，你明白我的意思吗？
Like, yeah.
就像，是的。
Okay, the Green Testical Guy was me.
好吧，绿色睾丸男就是我。
You're right, you know what I mean.
你是对的，你知道我的意思。
I also, you know, speaking about Barney, you think he's gonna transform it.
我也，你知道，谈到巴尼，你认为他会改变它。
We've talked about this, Craig, but I remember this great editor I worked with on both my movies, Michael Miller.
克雷格，我们已经讨论过这个问题，但我记得在我的两部电影中与我合作的这位伟大的剪辑师，迈克尔·米勒。
He talked about the difference between film and TV or one of the main differences.
他谈到了电影和电视之间的区别或者说主要区别之一。
On TV shows, a transformation has to be much slower because you're trying to establish these characters and they have their groove, they have their lane.
在电视节目中，转变必须要慢得多，因为你试图塑造这些角色，他们有自己的节奏，有自己的风格。
And you slowly, slowly transform them, but you can't transform them too quickly, or the show is over.
你慢慢地、慢慢地改变它们，但你不能太快地改变它们，否则表演就结束了。
Whereas in a movie, you've got to transform them in 90 minutes or two hours, like transformation happened to much speedier.
而在电影中，你必须在 90 分钟或两个小时内改变它们，就像转变发生得更快一样。
And I, you know, thinking about, you plant the seeds for, okay, there's a different guy underneath this suit.
我，你知道，在想，你播下了种子，好吧，这套衣服下面有一个不同的人。
The suit is armor, the suit is a character, he's playing at being a villain on some level, but it's a, it's a, it's a character he's not done playing.
这套衣服是盔甲，这套衣服是一个角色，他在某种程度上扮演的是一个恶棍，但这是一个他还没有扮演完的角色。
He's going to keep playing it.
他会继续玩下去。
So tune in next week, he's still going to be this guy.
所以下周请注意，他仍然是这个人。
Yeah.
是的。
And eventually over time, he's got, we saw more and more, we really got back to Barney's childhood.
最终随着时间的推移，我们看到了越来越多的东西，我们真的回到了巴尼的童年。
And we saw, we really saw where that guy began, where all the wounds went and sort of connected that through land, but the gift of long-form TV is getting to discover that, getting to peel back those layers.
我们看到了，我们真的看到了那个家伙从哪里开始，所有的伤口都去了哪里，并通过陆地将它们连接起来，但是长篇电视的礼物正在发现这一点，揭开这些层。
We didn't know all of that.
这一切我们都不知道。
We didn't know Barney was a hippie until we said that, it'd be funny.
直到我们这么说之前我们都不知道巴尼是个嬉皮士，这很有趣。
It'd be funny.
这会很有趣。
It'd be funny to have him, isn't that weird?
拥有他会很有趣，不是很奇怪吗？
It was like a dorm scene.
这就像宿舍场景。
The next eight years, like you then, almost like the vomit free, like you have to contend with the things you lay down because they have a cascade of consequences from that.
接下来的八年，就像你当时一样，几乎就像没有呕吐物一样，就像你必须应对你放下的东西，因为它们会产生一系列后果。
Paint yourself into a corner and that's, that will even get out of it.
把自己逼入墙角，甚至可以摆脱困境。
Watch how to get out of it.
看看如何摆脱它。
The necessity is the mother of invention, like you have to make yourself solve that problem.
需求是发明之母，就像你必须让自己解决这个问题一样。
Yeah, and Chris, I feel like you, in, okay, awesome, I remember the moment where we realized the narrator could have forgotten to tell you a crucial detail.
是的，克里斯，我感觉就像你一样，好吧，太棒了，我记得我们意识到叙述者可能忘记告诉你一个关键细节的那一刻。
Oh, yes.
哦是的。
I remember the idea of this.
我记得这个想法。
Oh, by the way, you had this dental procedure earlier in the day and you freeze frame.
哦，顺便说一下，你当天早些时候做了牙科手术，然后你就定格了。
And like, we are still finding it.
就像，我们仍在寻找它。
We're finding the moves and this episode is the template for so many of those future round table flashback episodes where we learned you need a present day conundrum.
我们正在寻找行动，这一集是未来许多圆桌倒叙集的模板，我们了解到你需要解决当前的难题。
You know what I mean?
你知道我的意思？
The flashbacks need to have twists and turns of their own.
闪回需要有自己的曲折。
You need each flashback to be different one from the other.
你需要每个闪回都彼此不同。
You need to be really moving the story forward in the present or else it's just like a clip show.
你需要真正推动故事在当下向前发展，否则它就像一场剪辑秀。
Like this was us figuring out how to do that kind of episode.
就像我们正在思考如何制作这样的一集。
We did a whole bunch more kind of like this one.
我们做了很多类似这样的事情。
And it was so fun and you're right, we were sort of clawing away and sometimes feeling our way in the dark.
这太有趣了，你是对的，我们有点挣扎，有时在黑暗中摸索。
at some point in the room like just us realizing, oh, the flashback can't just show what we just said it was going to show, which, like, you know, I've seen that pitfall in other places.
在房间里的某个时刻，就像我们意识到的那样，哦，闪回不能只显示我们刚才所说的它将要显示的内容，就像，你知道，我在其他地方看到过这个陷阱。
And yeah, I think you're right, that present-day story is the most important thing because that's what's carrying you through the great story in the past.
是的，我认为你是对的，当今的故事是最重要的，因为它带领你经历过去的伟大故事。
In regards to this talk of Barney and his origin story, Josh, would you like to introduce Chris to this our very important section.
关于巴尼和他的起源故事乔什的谈话，你想向克里斯介绍我们非常重要的部分吗？
Yeah, this is a now beloved section of the show that we like to call questions and observations from a clinical psychologist who's never seen how I met your mother and also happens to be married to Josh.
是的，这是节目中现在深受喜爱的部分，我们喜欢将其称为临床心理学家的问题和观察，他从未见过我是如何认识你母亲的，而且碰巧与乔什结婚了。
This episode, to me, is really like the Barney origin story, and I think it's great.
对我来说，这一集真的很像巴尼的起源故事，我认为这很棒。
It gave me so much more of an understanding of him, explanation for his behavior, for is bravado.
这让我对他有了更多的了解，对他的行为有了更多的解释，因为他是虚张声势。
It's like, oh, right.
就像，哦，对了。
It all comes from a broken heart.
这一切都源于一颗破碎的心。
Of course it does.
当然可以。
His insensitivity, quote-unquote, you know, is actually a way to protect himself from how deeply sensitive he is and how wounded he was from making himself incredibly vulnerable.
你知道，他的麻木不仁，实际上是一种保护自己的方式，以保护自己免受他自己如此敏感的伤害，以及他因使自己变得极其脆弱而受到的伤害。
So I don't have that much to say other than that, it's a good reminder that this is almost always the case that the the people who present as tough and invulnerable were often once very sensitive, but that part of them has been hurt and has subsequently gone underground.
所以除此之外我没什么可说的，这是一个很好的提醒，几乎总是这样，那些表现得坚强和无懈可击的人往往曾经非常敏感，但他们的那部分受到了伤害，随后转入地下。
Not a lot of talk about how handsome the writer of the episode is, but you know, it's like other than that.
没有太多谈论这一集的作者有多英俊，但你知道，事实并非如此。
We had another one and I killed that.
我们还有一个，我杀了它。
I killed that one.
我杀了那个人。
I was like, that's an approach.
我当时想，这是一种方法。
I don't want you doing that one.
我不想让你做那件事。
Do one about Barney.
做一个关于巴尼的事。
No, it's a great observation.
不，这是一个很棒的观察。
It's totally.
完全是这样
You need to see that side of Barney.
你需要看到巴尼的那一面。
You need to see that side of Barney or he's not interesting anymore.
你需要看到巴尼的另一面，否则他就不再有趣了。
He's only interesting, I think, because we get to see where it comes from.
我认为他之所以有趣，是因为我们可以看到它从何而来。
I think that's what makes him so much more human.
我认为这就是让他变得更加人性化的原因。
It's also counter-intuitive culturally, especially for men.
从文化角度来看，这也是违反直觉的，尤其是对于男性而言。
Like, I love the phrase rudeness is the weak man's attempt at strength.
就像，我喜欢“粗鲁是弱者试图获得力量”这句话。
You know, there's something about, especially in the moment we're in where there's so much confusion about masculinity and what is healthy masculinity, and there's these forward facing louder men in the world that are much more actually bro-cody.
你知道，有一些事情，特别是在我们现在对男子气概和什么是健康的男子气概有如此多的困惑的时候，世界上有一些面向前方、声音更大的男人，他们实际上更加兄弟情谊。
You know, they're much more kind of, and we've gotten in the weeds on some of this, but I'm sure we'll unpack it more just like, you know, you guys were not holding up Barney as any kind of exemplar of like male behavior.
你知道，他们更加善良，我们已经在其中一些问题上陷入了困境，但我相信我们会更多地解开它，就像，你知道，你们并没有把巴尼视为任何类似男性行为的典范。
Like you were, you know, you guys are all, it was a writer's room of Ted's and Marshall's, you know, the man, right?
就像你们以前一样，你们知道，你们都是，那是特德和马歇尔的作家房间，你知道，那个男人，对吧？
Like it wasn't, I think it's just useful to remember that vulnerability, especially publicly is quite difficult and requires an enormous amount of strength.
事实并非如此，我认为记住这种脆弱性是有用的，尤其是在公开场合，这是相当困难的，需要巨大的力量。
And I think being kind of shut down and rude doesn't.
我认为有点封闭和粗鲁则不然。
So I don't know, I still, I love and appreciate Barney as a character, but I think you have to watch him with the right understanding.
所以我不知道，我仍然喜欢并欣赏巴尼这个角色，但我认为你必须以正确的理解来观看他。
Yeah.
是的。
That's interesting.
那很有意思。
There is that danger of like the thing that we're mocking is the thing that people love about the character, genuinely love instead of loving to laugh at.
存在这样一种危险：我们嘲笑的东西正是人们喜爱这个角色的东西，是真正喜爱而不是喜欢嘲笑。
I think season one, we actually did a very good job of showing like, oh, Barney, to this point in season one, he has not succeeded in hugging up with that many women.
我认为第一季，我们实际上做得很好，表现得像，哦，巴尼，在第一季的这一点上，他还没有成功地拥抱那么多女人。
He's been very concerned about whether Ted's his best friend or not.
他一直非常关心特德是否是他最好的朋友。
And we learned that he used to be a hippie who had his heart broken.
我们了解到他曾经是一个心碎的嬉皮士。
Like, I really like how in season one, we did keep our eye on the ball, I think, of like, this guy, there's a lot underneath that suit.
就像，我真的很喜欢在第一季中，我们确实把注意力集中在球上，我想，就像这个家伙，在那套衣服下面有很多东西。
this episode is basically that.
这一集基本上就是这样。
That's the core of this episode is what's underneath that suit.
这就是这一集的核心，那就是那件衣服下面的东西。
And I think in later seasons, sometimes we lost sight of that for different patches of time and started to lose the kind of ironic distance from it and sometimes did the thing rather than were ironically commenting on the thing.
我认为在后来的几季中，有时我们在不同的时间段里忽视了这一点，并开始失去与它的那种讽刺性的距离，有时会做这件事，而不是讽刺地评论这件事。
What I like about this episode is we're saying, this is the premise here.
我喜欢这一集的地方是我们要说的是，这是这里的前提。
The premise here is there is someone who is inside of a Darth Vader costume and there's more to him than meets the eye and that's so much more interesting than a guy who like just hooks up with lots of women and like seems really cool like I want to see what who is that guy really and that's that's what's that's the best part of this episode.
这里的前提是，有一个人穿着达斯·维达的服装，他比表面上看到的更多，这比一个喜欢和很多女人勾搭的人有趣得多，而且看起来很酷，就像我想看看那个人到底是谁，这就是这一集最好的部分。
So I'm just curious just from this vantage point you know it's been 11 years since the show ended it's been 20 years since the show premiered so I'm just curious like when you look back on that time like what are your biggest memories what do you what do you feel when you see how I met your mother in the world, when you hear about all these younger generations discovering the show.
所以我只是从这个有利的角度好奇，你知道距离这部剧结束已经过去了 11 年，距离这部剧首播已经过去了 20 年，所以我很好奇，当你回顾那段时光，比如你最大的记忆是什么，当你看到我如何在世界上遇见你的母亲，当你听到所有这些年轻一代发现这部剧时，你有什么感受。
I mean, you were at the absolute epicenter of this for the entire run.
我的意思是，在整个跑步过程中，你绝对处于这件事的中心。
So like, where does how I met your mother live with you?
那么，我是怎么认识你妈妈的，你和你住在哪里？
What are your thoughts on that?
您对此有何看法？
I think one thing that we wanted was having been on plenty of shows before and plenty of shows after, if you get a great show, great people around you or great hours, if you get one of those on a show, then you're lucky.
我认为我们想要的一件事是，之前参加过很多演出，之后也参加过很多演出，如果你得到了一场精彩的演出，周围有很棒的人，或者很棒的时间，如果你在一场演出中得到了其中一个，那么你很幸运。
One thing we were good at was being aware in the moment of how fortunate we all were to be working with each other.
我们擅长的一件事就是意识到我们彼此合作是多么幸运。
I give Cardin Craig all the credit in the world, along with Pam and Susie for fostering that, appreciating where we are and what we get to do.
我把全世界所有的功劳都归功于卡丁·克雷格，还有帕姆和苏西，他们促进了这一点，感谢我们所处的位置和我们要做的事情。
Honestly, I've carried, not to sound too mushy, but I've I've carried that with me for these past decades, and I'm incredibly grateful for it.
老实说，我一直带着这一点，不要听起来太糊涂，但在过去的几十年里，我一直带着它，我对此非常感激。
I was at a talking at a school a few days ago, and this teacher in his probably mid-20s just came up and said, I can't believe you wrote for how much.
几天前我在一所学校的一次演讲中，这位大约二十多岁的老师走过来说，我不敢相信你写了这么多。
Like, you know, still excited.
就像，你知道，仍然很兴奋。
Another friend, his 12-year-old daughter just finished the run of the series, which I mixed feelings about knowing some of the things that we wrote, but I still love it.
另一位朋友，他 12 岁的女儿刚刚完成了该系列的运行，我对了解我们写的一些内容感到复杂，但我仍然喜欢它。
And I also, there's one, I don't know why this is the one moment I remember, but hearing the Josh who gave us that intro, his story about addiction, everything.
我也，有一个，我不知道为什么这是我记得的那一刻，但听到乔希给我们介绍了，他关于成瘾的故事，一切。
I always remember this one moment midway through the series being at some event or something, and the rest of the event I don't remember, but all I remember is this one woman saying, Thanks for making my Mondays a little happier.
我总是记得在系列赛中途参加某个活动或其他活动的那一刻，而活动的其余部分我不记得了，但我只记得这个女人说，谢谢你让我的星期一更快乐一点。
And, you know, I think that's wonderful that we got to do something that we all believed in and all loved and got to put out there and hopefully made brief little moments of different people's lives a little happier.
而且，你知道，我认为我们必须做一些我们都相信、都喜欢的事情，并且必须把它放在那里，并希望让不同的人生活中短暂的小时刻变得更快乐，这真是太棒了。
So yeah, I think we knew in the moment, especially as that last season started to happen, like this might, we might never have a job as this.
所以，是的，我想我们当时就知道，尤其是上个赛季开始发生时，就像这样，我们可能永远不会有这样的工作。
It might, yes.
可能是的。
And that's okay, because we got to have this job.
没关系，因为我们必须得到这份工作。
You know, we got to have these amazing nine years.
你知道，我们必须度过这令人惊奇的九年。
So much as I would love to do another show that I care about as deeply as that, I'm really happy that I got to do this one.
尽管我很想再做另一部我如此关心的节目，但我真的很高兴能做这个。
Craig, maybe let's interrogate this.
克雷格，也许我们要问一下这个。
It's not an issue now because people are watching this whatever they want.
现在这不是问题了，因为人们想看什么就看什么。
But it just occurred to me and said, thank you for making my Mondays better.
但我突然想到，谢谢你让我的周一变得更好。
Mondays are hard days.
周一是艰难的日子。
Mondays the start of the week.
星期一是一周的开始。
Mondays like you got the whole week ahead of you.
周一就像你还有整整一周的时间。
And that we were on Monday nights.
我们是在周一晚上。
I think that's like a little bit part of the story in a weird way.
我认为这就像故事的一小部分，以一种奇怪的方式。
I think so too.
我也这么认为。
I think we were on Monday night.
我想我们是在星期一晚上。
You had to slog your way through Monday.
你必须努力度过周一。
And if you watched Monday night, there we were for you.
如果您观看了周一晚上的节目，我们就为您服务。
And it was once a week.
而且是每周一次。
And that's how people consume the show.
这就是人们消费这个节目的方式。
And young people have no idea quite the felt like to consume the show in that way.
年轻人完全不知道以这种方式观看演出的感觉。
Though I will say that we have gotten not just one response online thanking people again for their Mondays, saying just like on the shows this week, this podcast comes out on Monday.
尽管我要说的是，我们在网上收到的不仅仅是一个回应，再次感谢人们的周一，就像本周的节目一样，这个播客在周一发布。
It's just like we wait for the show on Monday, we wait for the podcast.
就像我们等待周一的节目一样，我们等待播客。
I just want to say Chris Harris is the dream writer to have on your writing staff and has been an amazing showrunner of other stuff now too.
我只想说克里斯·哈里斯是你们写作团队中的梦想作家，而且现在也是其他作品的出色制作人。
And like, Chris, thank you.
克里斯，谢谢你。
You will be back on this podcast.
您将回到这个播客。
You wrote so many frickin' all-timers.
你写了那么多该死的历史著作。
Like every episode you wrote was great.
就像你写的每一集都很棒。
I would say as an actor, when I would open that Manila envelope with, you know, I think on a Friday, they'd often have the Monday's table read episode waiting for you.
我想说，作为一名演员，当我打开马尼拉信封时，你知道，我想在周五，他们经常会在周一的桌子上播放剧集等着你。
And when I opened it up and I saw written by Chris Harris, I was like, all right, this is gonna be good.
当我打开它，看到克里斯·哈里斯写的，我想，好吧，这会很好。
I'm excited about this.
我对此感到很兴奋。
There was always something in there that could only come from Chris.
那里总是有一些只能来自克里斯的东西。
Many things in there that could only come from Chris.
那里的很多东西只能来自克里斯。
And I think that is just such a testament That's the dream, I will say, as a showrunner of a TV show, that's the dream where somebody that can understand what the show is and bring the tone emotionally, bring the storytelling chops, but then do something with it that you yourself could never do and like Chris, like you just so have that talent.
我认为这就是一个证明，这就是梦想，我会说，作为电视节目的制作人，这是一个梦想，有人能够理解节目是什么，并在情感上带来基调，带来讲故事的技巧，然后用它做一些你自己永远做不到的事情，就像克里斯一样，就像你有那样的天赋一样。
It's just kind of innate talent of bringing jokes only you could write and moments only you could create and to all of your work, including your amazing children's books and poetry books.
这是一种与生俱来的天赋，可以将只有你能写的笑话和只有你能创造的时刻带到你的所有作品中，包括你精彩的儿童读物和诗歌书籍。
So go look those up, Chris is a genius at that too.
所以去查一下吧，克里斯在这方面也是个天才。
these final books.
这些最后的书。
Playing James Bond and the hot things like it's great.
扮演詹姆斯·邦德和诸如此类的热门事物真是太棒了。
They're amazing.
他们太棒了。
She's extraordinary.
她很非凡。
That's what it is.
就是这样。
You're amazing in that.
你在这方面很了不起。
I love you in Fleabag.
我爱《伦敦生活》里的你。
We love you Chris Harris and you will be back.
我们爱你克里斯·哈里斯，你会回来的。
I love you guys can't wait and yeah you built the playground.
我爱你们，你们已经等不及了，是的，你们建造了游乐场。
It was so much fun to play around it.
围绕它玩起来非常有趣。
So we tend to open these episodes with audio that you guys have submitted about how I met your mother means to you and we tend to close the show with written letters we've received about what how I met your mother means to you.
因此，我们倾向于以你们提交的关于我如何遇见你们母亲对你们意味着什么的音频来开始这些剧集，并且我们倾向于以我们收到的关于我如何遇见你们母亲对你们意味着什么的书面信件来结束节目。
If you would like to submit either an audio or a written letter, please go to how we made your mother.com, go to contact, should be clear from there.
如果您想提交音频或书面信件，请访问我们如何制作您的 mother.com，转到联系方式，那里应该很清楚。
We have a wonderful letter today, and I often read these letters, but today I'm handing it over to Chris Harris.
今天我们收到一封很棒的信，我经常读这些信，但今天我把它交给克里斯·哈里斯。
Chris will you read us our closing letter?
克里斯，你能给我们读一下我们的结束信吗？
Your first mistake.
你的第一个错误。
Here we go.
开始了。
Dear Josh and Craig, I was 12 years old the first time I watched How I Met Your Mother, which admittedly may have been a little too young for some of the more adult themes.
亲爱的乔什和克雷格，我第一次观看《老爸老妈的浪漫史》时才 12 岁，不可否认，对于一些更成人的主题来说，这部影片可能有点太年轻了。
We've been over this.
我们已经讨论过了。
Yeah.
是的。
This keeps coming up today.
今天这个问题不断出现。
But I had overheard my cousin talking about how great the show was, and I convinced my mom to get a Netflix subscription just so I could see it for myself.
但我无意中听到我表弟谈论这部剧有多精彩，我说服妈妈订阅了 Netflix，这样我就可以亲眼看到它了。
At the time, I was incredibly lonely and already experiencing my first round of depression.
当时，我感到非常孤独，并且已经经历了第一轮抑郁症。
I didn't have the words for it back then, but I knew that coming home and putting on how I met your mother felt like a lifeline.
当时我无法用言语形容，但我知道回家并展示我遇见你母亲的样子感觉就像是一条生命线。
It gave me a group of friends I could visit every day.
它给了我一群我每天都可以拜访的朋友。
It made me laugh when nothing else could.
当没有其他事情可以让我发笑时，它让我发笑。
It gave me hope that things could get better even when they felt impossible.
它给了我希望，即使事情感觉不可能，事情也会变得更好。
The show has become this rhythm in my life.
演出已经成为我生活中的节奏。
As soon as I finish the final episode, I go right back to the pilot episode.
当我完成最后一集时，我会立即回到试播集。
comfort, it's home, it's safe.
舒适，这是家，很安全。
A while ago, I got a tattoo that says, right time, right place, from Ted's speech in season four, episode 22.
不久前，我纹了一个纹身，上面写着“正确的时间，正确的地点”，来自泰德在第四季第 22 集的演讲。
When I finally went to New York, I made my friends come with me to McGee's Pub and I cried.
当我最终去纽约时，我让我的朋友和我一起去麦吉酒吧，我哭了。
Not in a touristy, I'm checking this off my bucket list kind of way, but because stepping into that bar felt like stepping into a place that had held me through some of the darkest and brightest moments of my life.
不是在旅游胜地，我以某种方式将其从我的愿望清单上划掉，而是因为走进那个酒吧感觉就像走进一个曾经帮助我度过生命中最黑暗和最光明时刻的地方。
My heart felt full and strange and overwhelmed.
我的心感到充实、陌生、不知所措。
Like I was visiting an old friend, I'd only ever known through a screen.
就像我拜访一位老朋友一样，我只是通过屏幕认识的。
I could have stayed there forever.
我本可以永远呆在那里。
I did not want to leave.
我不想离开。
Listening to your podcast has brought that world to life in a whole new way.
收听您的播客以全新的方式让这个世界变得栩栩如生。
It's filled me with so much joy and nostalgia, and one of the letters you read moved me more than I expected.
它让我充满了欢乐和怀旧，你读到的其中一封信比我预想的更让我感动。
It touched on things I've felt too, and for a moment I worried that writing to you would seem repetitive, but I've come to realize that's the magic of this show.
它也触及了我的感受，有一段时间我担心给你写信会显得重复，但我逐渐意识到这就是这个节目的魔力。
It created something so personal for so many of us, something that still connects people across time, distance, and circumstance.
它为我们许多人创造了如此个性化的东西，仍然可以跨越时间、距离和环境将人们联系在一起。
So thank you.
所以谢谢你。
Thank you for creating a show that's felt like home to me for over a decade, for giving us a group of characters who felt like friends, each of them flawed and funny and deeply human in ways that made me feel less alone.
感谢你们创作了一部十多年来让我感觉像家一样的剧，感谢你们给了我们一群感觉像朋友的角色，他们每个人都有缺陷，但很有趣，而且很有人性，让我感觉不那么孤独。
And thank you for the podcast.
感谢您的播客。
Hearing your stories, reflections, and laughter has felt like revisiting something sacred with the people who made it.
听到你的故事、反思和笑声，感觉就像和创造它的人一起重温一些神圣的东西。
It's been emotional, funny, and healing in ways I didn't expect.
它以我意想不到的方式充满情感、有趣和治愈。
How I met your mother has shaped me.
我与你母亲的相遇塑造了我。
It's helped me hold on when things felt heavy and reminded me to believe in love, timing, and the kind of friendship that makes everything else bearable.
当事情变得沉重时，它帮助我坚持下去，并提醒我相信爱情、时机和那种让其他一切都可以忍受的友谊。
Thank you from the bottom of my heart for this amazing show.
我从心底感谢你们给我带来了这场精彩的演出。
Sincerely, Louie from The Farrow Islands.
此致，来自法罗群岛的路易。
Wow.
哇。
And nice is that.
这很好。
That's Chris.
那是克里斯。
Isn't that cool?
这不是很酷吗？
We've heard from fans and it's such an honor that we all got to make something that meant as much to people like that.
我们收到了粉丝们的来信，我们非常荣幸能够制作出对这样的人来说同样重要的作品。
That's amazing.
太棒了。
And so humbling to, yeah, thank you for sharing that.
非常谦卑，是的，谢谢你分享这一点。
It's beautiful.
很美丽。
And to point this out, the feeling of friendship in the show, we all really were friends.
需要指出的是，节目中的友谊感，我们真的都是朋友。
I think the idea, the writing staff and the actors, we're all kind of similar ages and similar vibes.
我认为这个想法、编剧和演员，我们都有相似的年龄和相似的氛围。
We all really were friends.
我们真的都是朋友。
And Chris Harris, just to say this, and you can only say Chris Harris' name, you've got to say both names.
克里斯·哈里斯（Chris Harris），只是这么说，你只能说克里斯·哈里斯的名字，你必须说两个名字。
You can't just say Chris Harris, you have to say Chris Harris, he's one of those guys.
你不能只说克里斯·哈里斯，你必须说克里斯·哈里斯，他就是其中之一。
that Chris is such a dear friend of mine and of Carter's.
克里斯是我和卡特的挚友。
Like we really do go back in our 20s.
就像我们真的回到了20多岁一样。
We were writing for Late Show with David Letterman.
我们正在为《大卫·莱特曼深夜秀》撰稿。
We were going to McGee's pub on Thursday nights as a group right from the, that was the Late Show with David Letterman bar before it was the, now it's the how I met your mother bar, but it was the Late Show with David Letterman bar first.
我们周四晚上一起去麦吉酒吧，之前是大卫·莱特曼深夜秀酒吧，现在是我遇见你妈妈的酒吧，但首先是大卫·莱特曼深夜秀酒吧。
And we would go there, Chris, to sort of drink our troubles away after a long week.
克里斯，我们会去那里，在漫长的一周后通过喝酒来消除我们的烦恼。
We'd do two shows, two tapings of Letterman on Thursday night.
周四晚上我们会做两场演出，两段莱特曼的录音。
It was a great job, but it was very intense.
这是一项很棒的工作，但也非常紧张。
And we would, we would be there.
我们会的，我们会在那里。
And so Chris is like really such a dear friend of Carter and I, and came with us from the hair, and there was a little gap time where we weren't working together, but we were together on a couple of other things prior to how much a mother.
所以克里斯就像卡特和我的好朋友一样，从头发开始就和我们一起来了，有一点间隙时间我们没有一起工作，但我们在做母亲之前就一起做了其他几件事。
Most of my TV career was with you, Chris.
我的大部分电视生涯都是和你一起度过的，克里斯。
Is that I think that friendship and history that we all had, and so many of us had on the writing staff, and with the cast, I think it does translate into the final product.
我认为我们所有人以及我们中的许多人在写作人员和演员阵容中所拥有的友谊和历史，我认为它确实转化为最终产品。
And maybe that's what this person who wrote this amazing letter was feeling.
也许这就是写这封令人惊叹的信的人的感受。
I like to think that's part of it.
我喜欢认为这是其中的一部分。
Absolutely.
绝对地。
It felt like for a while, it felt like how much a mother, Like, our lives were just a few years ahead of the characters.
有一段时间，感觉就像一个母亲，就像，我们的生活只比角色提前了几年。
And so just enough to let us reflect, but all of those times, I think you're right.
这足以让我们反思，但所有这些时候，我认为你是对的。
I think that friendship and that genuine caring for each other really came through.
我认为友谊和彼此真诚的关心确实是通过的。
Just to sort of emphasize how connected we were as both, you know, we were writers on this show, but also friends, I, when I was scrolling through the notes for doing game night.
只是为了强调我们之间的联系，你知道，我们是这个节目的编剧，也是朋友，当我滚动浏览游戏之夜的笔记时。
Is that game going to find out secrets about each other or the rules are variable?
该游戏是否会发现彼此的秘密，或者规则是可变的？
They keep changing.
他们不断变化。
And then it reads chain reaction reveal of dirt on other characters.
然后它会读取其他角色身上污垢的连锁反应。
Barney's got something on Rob and Lily on Barney.
巴尼对罗布有了解，莉莉对巴尼有了解。
And then the next line, it says, Chris Harris boy names.
然后下一行写着克里斯·哈里斯男孩的名字。
And what is clearly happening here is my wife was pregnant and the room had paused to pitch on names for, for my child, it goes, Chris Harris boy names.
这里显然发生的事情是我的妻子怀孕了，房间里停下来为我的孩子命名，据说是克里斯·哈里斯男孩的名字。
Casper, which, Casper, Jughead, Woody Woodpecker, SpongeBob, King Awesome, Chris Harris is- You went with King Awesome, you went with King Awesome.
Casper，Casper、Jughead、啄木鸟伍迪、海绵宝宝、King Awesome、Chris Harris 是——你和 King Awesome 一起去了，你和 King Awesome 一起去了。
You did awesome.
你做得真棒。
You went with King Awesome and never looked back.
你和 King Awesome 一起走了，再也没有回头。
Chris Harris, girl names, Helga Sudoku Betty.
克里斯·哈里斯，女孩名字，赫尔加数独贝蒂。
That's how the notes page ends.
笔记页面就这样结束了。
That's how the notes for that day end.
那天的笔记就这样结束了。
I also like, it's like an incredibly tender moment and tender ask, like, what's my friends?
我也喜欢，这就像一个令人难以置信的温柔时刻，温柔地问，比如，我的朋友是什么？
What did they think?
他们怎么想？
They're like, jughead, college jughead.
他们就像，傻瓜，大学傻瓜。
I am guilty, please equip me.
我有罪，请装备我。
All sins are forgiven, New York City.
纽约市，所有罪孽都被宽恕。
How we made your mother is hosted an executive produced by Josh Radner and Craig Thomas.
《我们如何造就你的母亲》由乔什·拉德纳和克雷格·托马斯担任执行制片人主持。
The show was produced by me, Alec Lev, and our co-producer is Doug Matica.
该节目由我 Alec Lev 制作，我们的联合制作人是 Doug Matica。
Our audio producer and mixer is Alex Reeves, Point of Blue Studios, and our digital content producer, A.K.A.
我们的音频制作人和混音师是 Point of Blue Studios 的 Alex Reeves，我们的数字内容制作人是 A.K.A.
Gen Z Master, is Emily Blumberg.
Z 世代大师是艾米丽·布隆伯格 (Emily Blumberg)。
Artwork by John Morrow.
约翰·莫罗的艺术作品。
Please follow, rate, and review the show on Apple Podcasts or your podcast player of choice.
请在 Apple 播客或您选择的播客播放器上关注、评分和评论该节目。
It really does help the show.
对节目确实有帮助。
Our theme song is NYC by our own Josh Radner with additional music by Craig Thomas and Andrew Majuski.
我们的主题曲是我们自己的 Josh Radner 创作的《NYC》，其他音乐由 Craig Thomas 和 Andrew Majuski 创作。
Special thanks to Lola Kennedy and Elliot Connors.
特别感谢洛拉·肯尼迪和埃利奥特·康纳斯。
Visit HowWeMajorMother.com to sign up for our Substack mailing list and for links to our social media.
请访问 HowWeMajorMother.com 注册我们的 Substack 邮件列表以及我们社交媒体的链接。
You can also click on the contact page to send us an email or a voice message.
您还可以单击联系页面向我们发送电子邮件或语音消息。
Your stories and questions are an important part of the show.
您的故事和问题是节目的重要组成部分。
Want some merch?
想要一些商品吗？
Click on the store link or go to HowYouGetYourMerch.com.
单击商店链接或访问 HowYouGetYourMerch.com。
Subscribe to Josh Radner's Muse Letters on Substack.
在 Substack 上订阅 Josh Radner 的 Muse Letters。
Order Craig Thomas' debut novel at CraigThomasWriter.com slash novel, and you could subscribe to my Dead Fathers Society also on Substack.
在 CraigThomasWriter.com 斜线小说上订购克雷格·托马斯的处女作，您也可以在 Substack 上订阅我的《死去的父亲协会》。
To learn about how you make a difference, this shows ongoing campaign to raise money for congenital heart disease research.
要了解您如何做出改变，这显示了正在进行的为先天性心脏病研究筹集资金的活动。
Check out the Make a Difference tab at the top of our website.
查看我们网站顶部的“Make a Difference”选项卡。
This episode was made possible by the support of Backyard Ventures.
这一集是在 Backyard Ventures 的支持下才得以实现的。
People will, in fact, dance.
事实上，人们会跳舞。
It just hit me am I in love with you or just New York City
我突然意识到我是爱你还是只爱纽约市